and we go so hopefully that made it in time
alright so let's do this
let's do this let's do this
you the whole starting stream think you
might listen to just give you about five
minutes to start I know some people who want
to really cover the stuff so I don't want to
I don't I don't want to do it like too fast
and when I can move the time so we just I'll
give you guys 5 minutes I'm going to go make
some coffee I'll be right back
Bogdan
oh and lots of stuff we got raided I didn't
do a lot of streaming it was just a dream
but it's funny cuz I mentioned you I was
thinking you and we got like 3,000 people
rated as yesterday from learn of Leon doing
amazing things he's doing amazing things out
there
hey how's it going to be seen in a little
bit this is going to be a fast stream I'm
thinking maybe now or to the goal here is
all ice cream all the time I drink 24 7 no
ice creams I tell people about are the ones
on Saturday though because that's on the
counter
I just got to be rated nice all right so to
any of our beginners are out there right now
and wondering what's going on here like
why's this guy screaming ice cream all day
everyday like whenever I can I don't know
I've got my work up right here this is
called a cold learning and it's kind of a
co-worker streaming literally being paid for
this time so when I get to and I'm going to
be answering a lot of questions you can read
about this different kind of mode in my in
my about section but the point is is that
I'm doing work and I can I call Atco working
right so so you can come watch if you have a
little questions maybe the check can help
you answer the questions but if I don't
respond please don't be offended I have to
get work done so it's just an opportunity to
kind of over the shoulder and can I watch
the work I'm doing
formatting disc oh my God
love your trophy to buy tabs nice again I'm
going to make coffee be back in five minutes
when we come back if you want to follow
along and you don't know what to do when
you're a beginner in the first two things
you need to do is you need to install
virtualbox on your machine whenever whenever
you have need to get Versa box installed in
the second thing you need to do is install
vagrant and if you don't know how to do
those two things you can look at that you're
doing a liver but so far besides the lab
I can change my mind about vagrant vs.
terraform
yeah it was you if you get it did you get a
good laugh up there and then I can go look
at it I'll do that instead of using vagrant
maybe I don't know though I mean the biggest
the biggest of pill I have freezing vagrant
oh that's great thank you for saying so not
a lot of people are fond of ignorant I was
like cursing it I actually wrote a huge
scathing review sheet with vagrant when I
first did it I really hate it I hate it how
old it is excetera in its quirks and I just
found out that you have to update a box you
have to hit you can't to the cloud you can
we update box into the cloud you can't
update sets of boxes to the cloud which is
really lame is if I want to share something
with somebody I want to share a
configuration that has multiple boxes in it
and I just found out yesterday I could have
been missing something or so. You know any
different than a time there was a real
disappointment to the whole van Bakery cloud
sharing idea the idea of being able to share
my favorite configuration so I'm just going
to stick with you soon and I'll give you
posted that because I'm provisioning 3 and
provisioning 3 virtual machines at the same
time using vagrant
and in order to share those with somebody
else have to share his three separate boxes
but everybody is it is quite slow oh hell
yeah it's very slow but again the reason I'm
going to stick with a coronavirus boxes
because it's the default sad because you
can't use of energy to figure out if
experimental mode works for district for for
making vines
did you find that out yet according to the
documentation I read
from any proportion was talking about this
and we know you were telling me the colon
disc
yeah that you can't you can't Persian discs
unless you have live unless you have her box
I read those words I don't know if it's true
or not I read the words that you can't use
the hyper awesome you know disc provisioning
roll with without otherwise have to do that
big long convoluted shit is very specific
hey how's it going mashina macchina
that's why I wasn't trying for a positioning
oh I see so you skipped it because you
didn't want to have to use virtualbox with
that suturing terraform with liver which
makes it faster because liver is faster and
then you're doing your own volume to set up
Solitaire for me to ansible
yeah if you can if you get like an organized
laugh about that working and want to walk me
through that at some point that would be
fucking amazing hey Jordan welcome some
beginner videos beginner boost
now just keep in mind that the Boost that I
did in 2021 we use Docker and 2022 we're
going to let use virtualbox
so just know that's different yesterday was
nuts at a feeling it's it's a foreboding I
think it's going to get busier and hear
people and we're going to figure that out
all my regulars are going to be annoyed
because I'm not going to be able to have a
hug and kiss if you're do you know this I
talked to everybody all the time I have a
very very very interactive chatting as soon
as my check gets out of control or I can't
communicate with my regulars I'm going to be
sad I'm going to have to figure out what to
do with that how's it going Mitch macchina
Frank how you doing do the page my Converse
at each full stack with a teamwork task like
a real world
and I can pay to get a job that's cool I've
heard of it have you played around with that
super cool on that bring it up bring up on
Sunday again Frank if you remember if you
put that many could you put it up bring it
Sunday or put in the am a channel in Discord
so we don't lose it
any other great I'd like to talk about any
kind of I'd like to review new resources for
learning anytime that's kind of a Saturday
Sundays for thing it's so yeah I'm very open
to the possibility of Swiss chard turned
from an ansible LBG because obviously those
are more mainstream tools as their knowledge
in beginning would not would be more
relevant Negron is not so relevant today
it's at it's fine but it's just not as
modern Soul Eater from and asked if it would
be a much better use of your time if we can
make that work an ant but has to be very
seamless I don't want it to be let me come
out meet we did this whole entire thing and
at the end of the day I like Fifty lines of
vagrant that we're going to go get some
coffee so I'm going to walk away from now
and I will start very soon give you I'll
give you all a chance to come on in here if
you want to see how to 1 start up a virtual
startup kubernetes in a virtual machine in a
three birthstone
jeans on credit he's in automatically
configure that get them started and Nick
that's what that happens automatically and
then we're going to break it I might
actually break in a Mini Cooper I haven't
decided if I'm going he's bigger than me to
Que Viet and what we're going to do is we're
going to overburden a note with tons of like
fake jobs and and then we're going to take
that no down in a way that has it push those
jobs over to the other node so that it was
nobody nobody detects any loss of of work
happening and that is that is the girl has a
whole point of kubernetes and I feel feel
like this is it I need to do this actually
I'm looking at it right now that is this
over burn is God's is 6900 restart said it
needed it we need to do this in there is
probably like 300 jobs running on it so I
need to do this task I just I've only done
it once in development and I I want to make
sure they do it right I know it's a pretty
simple task that I still want to do it first
on my own
on my on my own system so I can get a handle
for it and not blow up the world in
production because I'd have to I have to do
this in production is pretty is really right
thing with kubernetes as you know what no
matter how bad things get they really don't
get a no pointer. He's just kind of keep you
available even if if stuff goes bad in and
that that's one of these things is there a
story all right. I forgot about it I got to
go back and review all my notes on it
ya aren't so at least let melet me slip away
45 minutes
remind me to write
got him I got to remember to do this got to
turn track to off again so this is Christmas
videos going to give
can you get muted but it'll just be the
first part I don't get Mewtwo not the whole
thing
there's a persistent process like you
control summer clothes go crazy
interesting not sure what that means
accurate and he's supposed to be scheduled
for capacity
I'm passing small available capacity on a
nobody fault is an issue because no simply
run quite a few system damage
cardio rest in peace unless resources side
for these Damon's
I'll just have names compete for resources
lead to restore starvation of a note as
actually problem we have right now actually
this is really good
and yes but you wouldn't give exposed to
Future named
I know the cable that helps us recovery
resources interesting okay this is
interesting all right
Alabama looking for this are CPUs not
alligator Mall
condemned as I get added to the list of
things I have to learn yeah
is it a bit Mo end
all right so again we are we are gathered
here today
to break shit and try to turn it off
so we're going to refer somebody to get
Renown cluster
uncontrolled playing coz when control plane
node into worker notes and I have a bigger
for sending the stuff I'm not sure we need
to go through that the energy of doing that
list actually try it with mini Q I feel like
make you would be a better use of this if
you have many things to pick from this point
is because your first time you can pick you
can do mini Cube which is what can raise
that I always tell you to do you can do kind
which does simulated containers inside of a
doctor or a simulated work or you can do
regular in which is a real version Moschino
so one of the things
as I go through our plan so but first you
need to set up a text with customers on
machines are going to make you all right so
we can do that first that might take a while
that depends on on stuff
on stuff and then what
so what's say say tasks the first task is
to drain now create
a
create as a fair number of
running
I see I guess you could do it kind of
diverse career fair
number of running containers
I have a lot of pods in Denver of and pods
on a node
on both nodes
worker nodes I'm doing because it's the name
and pies can be from
anything that creates I can be from any kind
of resource
kind of curious resource then Step 2
drain drain them
I almost want to give away what to do
because if I say drain and that gives away
what it is right
clear the clear clear out one of the nodes
from all
running pods such that taking
and taking it offline even if it
or power off I won't harm
anything that was running
and that's why we're doing this
now people should be making their
applications in in an ephemeral way unless
they're doing a statefulset and is
statefulset I kind of wonder about estate
for said
I just stopped it is only shit I'm going to
make me watch it right now aren't you
is Rancho just like going to take over for
dr.
Shit I think Rancho de steps a darker to
step out there it is
Rancher is Atlantic City
I want to see it I want to see it work
you got me you got me interested I got to
look at this right now because we weren't
doing the ends right
communities in container management desktop
astronomer using a mini Q micro Kate's now
that's about dinner 1300s
in a container in a movie
I just have rescued a container measuring on
your desktop you could use a recirculating
you want to run you can build push pull in
and rig taking her to the community
container image Evil 2 can run Charisma give
me without the user registry I think kind
kind of it does that
fuckfuck fuck yeah
is getting rid of it or if I can return this
is awesome
this is really awesome we need to do a full
thing on this
yeah I am I actually use this instead of
instead of dr.
Yeah this is this is really cool do doctor
is going to be hating it
I haven't used it before
does it the question is is will it work with
a VPN on Cisco anyconnect I have to try this
while I still have Cisco anyconnect on my
Windows machine
because the only reason I use Docker desktop
and I have to stop by my Windows machine is
because of Any connects Cisco VPN the new
cell does not work with Cisco anyconnect VPN
Docker desktop does because it's something
about the network Bridges works and so I'm
going to be cancer type things with him
did you really
if if if we install this is this person was
it free I'm sorry this is like really
important for vector company right now is
making a huge evaluation about how to
replace Target. And if this turns out to be
trying to get it to the right people
immediately so this is very relevant for
work and I'm kind of cold working right now
we're about to drop a ton of cash I think I
don't know I don't know for sure I'm just
conjecture in here but we're about to their
disgusting it all the subscription rates are
going to have to pay for everybody you need
to talk or just a I don't think of any
alternate and they're doing all kinds of
crazy shit like building Docker build you
know jump boxes and shit like that rather
than just letting people you sent me on
their desktop in there yeah so they're
enduring evaluation what about what to
replace it with and if there's actually a
legit if there's actually a legit thing that
gives them kubernetes in addition to doctor
Mini Cooper Mini Cooper with the slip board
on a Mac will work I mean it was a mini BBQ
with whatever
I would not use the movie setup actually
it's These doctor command
oh can hear you just and have the doctor
come on your right the Rachel that's right I
forgot
paradoxical life
is is some is there an independent project
from the community it must be
yeah
nurse until I really have to learn this
because we have a ton of users that are that
are back with their hands in the air like
this they have no idea what to do
so I'm really whoever told us about this I'm
happy to make a tangent real quick
cousin rccl a control Canario who has
exactly what we want
maybe if you happy if you weren't already
yeah golden projects
the thing is so great about this is it comes
to kubernetes so
you know it's kubernetes and it's darker as
long as it doesn't over-complicate shit or
machine learning people
will get frustrated to be like oh I don't
want other communities I just want my
bottles are running my images on dr. Give me
my doctor back if if if we if we you know if
we confuse them too much
I don't know
I don't I don't know
I hit the first thing I get that first thing
I have to explain him is like where your
doctor went to have to take all the work
clothes this is what I want actually want to
do a case study on this I want to do a case
they want to say okay here's is common
darker things that you did and hears it,
doctor things you can do now using ratchet
system and God knows I love Rancher I think
Rancho is a company and is an organization
and is in Project is fucking amazing I'm not
a fan of of you know Debbie 30s for four
communities administration because he's not
real but that's a different issue I'm really
important and personal Rancher thing it is
right
Ranchos de slack issues getting assumed I'm
guessing it's patchy yep
Apache cuz Apaches would businesses like oh
my God this is so awesome at one point oh
one point I was just released
one point I was just released an hour ago
fuck what the fuck
how did you find out about the so fast it's
only been out for a fucking our oh my God
the miracle of the internet
shit this is crazy I have to go I have to go
tell everybody about this right now
I have to tell my team about it right now
because and sentiments on it have you
it's amazing Porsche
dr. S e family front your desk can be run
with with with ranch dressing out of the box
I have to tell my team like now it back I'm
going to go to hashtag General channel to an
oz
as a person or company do nails Lockport a
bug to we stream live 1 hour ago
yeah
I know if you get the inside scoop that's
right you have a lot of internal demand you
to play right cuz that's why you did your
own thing instead of like doing vanilla Cube
ATM
I'm super excited by this and I love Rancho
so much more than redhead so
kind of laminate start that project I got to
start watching that
all activity every months ago it randomly
browsing get head
yeah yeah yeah it's actually not. Just up
anywhere right at stalker personal and
Doctor Enterprise
Admiral a proposal 21
the department has gone yeah I'm sorry I
moved all of the labs are still there
they're just all in a lab repo now so you
can wait you'll have to follow the one repo
you don't have to kind of track them all if
you just you can follow everything in one
little Networks
you know the agenda for today there's no
agenda I'm at work
so the main the main agenda today that I
came in here cuz it's a receipt so when I
strain during the day it's cuz I'm working
and so I usually is Coco working some kind
of all over the place if I change what I'm
doing or usually change the topic down here
but I started the day I started the day
doing kubernetes no safety offline cuz I
have to drain some communities notice so we
will be doing that don't worry about that we
will be doing that but but we just took a
big rabbit hole because an hour ago 1 hour
ago probably the most significant release in
the container world for end-users was was
made by the ranch or company and the more
I'm reading about this summer I'm being
blown away by this this is fucking huge news
you need to take your CTO is aside and go
hey remember that problem with having to pay
for subscription money into to Docker
desktop that is the deadline is at the end
of this month
remember that big problem we're going to end
up paying like thousands of dollars for
subscriptions or are we going to be charged
for penalties and here's a possible solution
to that
and I'm on my fact I I'm going to step away
for 5 minutes and I'm going to make a post
to my to my company right now about this cuz
it's such a fucking big deal so I'll be
right back I'm just I'm here I'm just I'm
just going to be AFK in bed
let me see here
what I want to say yeah I know.
I forgot what I called it God damn it
yeah but it's it's going to be this is kind
of a place to just hang out during the day
it's not really an agenda it's called
co-working so it kind of like a water cooler
and thank God it is because somebody from
our community just told us about this
fucking amazing news that just broke and I
wouldn't know about I was no way I would
have found out about it without my community
so this is why we just kind of turned it on
and leave it on during a workday
not going to stop I know you if you're easy
mac or Windows you need are going to stop if
you're a common
it's like a boot camp in May yep it's called
boost here you go
at 50 people in that people know people in
the chat can sometimes help you find us this
is my old one this old one we got a new one
coming but I'm I'm pretty I'm pretty far
away from a from
I'm at you'll see me working on that content
as well
if you want it if you want something to do
when your beginner go out and do the Boost
videos and it'll use containers and it'll
actually a teacher takes you through doctor
just stop in there and now you'll you'll
understand why I'm freaking out about this
other one
so
I don't I'm sorry if I sound like a
offending when I mean that was a snake, the
person I'm talking about I'm talking about
you know phds in machine learning you have
no legs feels what do we find Brianna
reported to us that an hour ago ranch or
desktop was announced 1.0 version of Rancho
desktop which is a full replacement for
Docker desktop which is a proprietary
software that there are now charging for and
there's the end of the year to the end of
the month deadline and corporate
corporations against thousands of dollars I
order or pay for her ask and beg for
forgiveness and belongings out of that is a
big deal for big Enterprise because a lot of
big Enterprise people people are raised on
your desktop cuz it's nice it's a nice super
happy easy to install that's why I didn't
come in the 2021 boost as we'd like click on
Docker desktop install it run Linux you're
going to go right it's super easy is really
really abusive friend Lee
I was your man it's got a number of bugs it
also works with anyconnect VPN wish to be a
cell does not answer to have to have an
alternative to that that's free at 70% free
and her Apache is a big fucking deal and it
just was announced an hour ago so I guess
I'm going to take a quick little break here
and I'm going to make I'm going to create it
I got to go in the crate is all the cast for
this really fast
Rancher desktop alternatives to Docker
desktop
I sure that stopped was just announced
I said I was just it was just an out rest of
the stuff 1.0
I just in time to help large companies deal
with the looming deadline to
start paying for their corporate
subscriptions to Docker desktop
this is huge all the alternatives
Heritage the date I have not been
at the same expectation of
of user-friendly interfaces
I have not but that I'm not the field
the same expectation of Drop Dead simple
user interfaces to doctor
looks like this one does with the added
bonus of providing a local securities
cluster out of box
instead of tacking it on like the darker
desktop tried and failed to do
this is fucking huge news for those making
Enterprise decisions
about container tooling for their developers
in the Enterprise
I don't need fucking in there I don't know
man we're going to see
it's like a rock years now yeah
God bless God bless his yeah
the problem with that Frank you know they
they say oh you don't need to worry you just
use Docker desktop but why on Earth would
you want to learn something that you can't
take with you into the Enterprise that
doesn't make any sense to me
the whole point of learning this shit I mean
come on how many unless you're an educator
or you're doing it on this side the chances
of you wanting to learn Docker just because
you're a hobbyist is very low the reason you
want to learn Docker and be productive on
your desktop with doctor is because you want
to carry that skill into the Enterprise in
your job
and by learning a tool that's going to limit
you
belonging to all this going to limit you it
makes ya NASA TV
oh thank you yeah I got it I got to go
report that one live with him I know it's
here
thank you thank you thank you Tony has been
helping me out with some of the so I can the
guys if they know people here we are this is
a co-working space right so we are doing the
same thing we would do if we all were four
different companies were sitting in a coffee
shop together right we're exchanging knows
we're getting our work done we're
interfacing with our individual teams and
we're helping each other out that's that's
what we do here
I want to meet the doctor hobbyist yeah
if I had a question with polecat
poke poke it is the one that we have no but
they already working in Ponca City right now
we're already having outages for that so
there's another one now that it's been kind
of bouncing around at the same time and I
can't remember I just randomly saw it I
wanted to I mentioned it on my status
meetings it has like there's another one out
there related to breaking out a dock or
somewhere I just want to make sure it's not
a repeat of the same thing we already know
that
so that might be the one
kids doctoral devops tools
a Rancher false
we can put a link here
major bug registry access yep that's the one
that the read axis one is the one
yeah I can you always bleeping computer
actually that's a really great blog of all
living computer has fantastic stuff they do
really great stuff
they do hey how they are
all right I'm stopping I don't put related
anymore I just write it sticks to his son
writing
or the other one where did who posted the
post thing
brownie
hey wolfram's on
is big fucking deal then
I can find some of those with more memory
you did this very task Victor pissed I miss
that really over your comment thank you for
saying that I need to do this test with this
is like this is like priority right now.
Still November Rancho desktop is coming out
how to link address
I like this nothing better I could just
cleaner to read
anybody else that links on this doctor
Jessup something I can put in this is that
before I publish it
I don't think it's like cockpit I don't know
what cockpit is I
yeah hey yo
yeah
well there you go boom that's on my Twitter
I just posted that to Twitter now you follow
my Twitter Twitter slash.com daughter BX Rob
so I charge extra on and I actually need to
send
a link to that
it's a hard thing cuz I I struggle with this
thing because I don't necessarily want to
tell everybody in my entire company that I
stream it's not like I'm hiding anything but
but I don't like blasting you know external
resources for stuff that I have been doing I
don't know how do you feel about Twitter
yeah I need to go send this though
I'm I'm really a torn right now it's a tool
that I made
it's not done by any means please don't it's
not finished just have any docs on it at all
I change it all the time but that's it if
you want to go take a peek other people have
copied it done different things some people
ported to go I've been so I need a portal
thing to go
is it going to go tell your dad you're
getting too used to lecture you lucky
oh my God you're surfing
oh my God I am so glad you're here you can
maybe I'm not too old to Surf right I still
want to learn to surf so bad I've surf like
four times total I do a lot of paddle
boarding but and I've surfed I'm surf waves
from the paddleboard which is way easier my
leg is a big old fat board
now you just got me off track and I'm just
inside by surfing all day I ain't fucking I
live in North Carolina and now I have a
super dad the Outback y'all
oh my God slow down I'm so glad you're here
to the Outer Banks is like 2 hours for Me 3
hours the Outer Banks you like Kick-Ass
surfing also lots of sharks
you know I can go there I can go there for a
week I could go surfing all week and then I
can stream and work
I've got an account I can't my GoPro I can't
my GoPro so I can go do it holy shit I
didn't even realize that my wife just bought
a car yesterday let me see how the Outback I
can actually buy I got my suit in there too
take away my suit with some I didn't give
him
oh man I am not look I have my bucket list
is to be able to actually know how to turn
on a wave that's on my bucket list
how much where can I get done I don't know
enough
seriously so my fucking bucket list and I'm
going to lose my knees and 54 I only have a
very short time window here before I can get
it
here we go from three days to run to the
surfing every honey I'm Sharp
what else is new yeah that is a really good
tangent though thank you for saying so you
just reminded me that I can actually go to
the beach again I have mail to go to the
beach and the shit like that and eat the
sushi and all that because my wife is a
deathly allergic to fish or I will kill her
three ways we got the Outer Banks coming up
I got some time I can plant in the spring or
something you know
God damn all these road trips coming up I
got it like make more money and I got to
work harder okay now back to work I got to
make money so I can go surfing
we got a Les Brewery absolutely killing me
We Love Our Lives room also we're both
lesbians
all right here's the question here's a
question do I send
do I send this link to my Twitter to my team
or do I send the individual links separately
from
from what's in my Twitter what do you think
is better
people calling was mobiles all the time and
you know what they don't have no idea I
lived in Utah it's like it's like the state
car of Utah and Colorado because why because
he's so flexible you can go skiing with it
after you can pay with cash on the top you
can sleep in it it's fantastic fact I'm
going to go mountain biking in Moab I'm
going to take the invert a call you with me
I am was just no reception over there is
nothing like a satellite or something
I thought I didn't mean to pry.
The people make fun of sooner or Subaru
Outback because they say lesbians on them
I was I was River got him a lot I was a
mountain bike guide for full year and I was
a river by guy dinmore if you if you want to
go we can organize oh my God we can organize
a white rim trail trip it's like a 3-day
trip on the White rim trail people do this
in a day like really monster mountain bikers
we could we could do we could do the white
rim trail I could totally guy that shit we
just we just need to get the equipment we
need to provision it we need I can probably
take it in my outbox the Outback and pull us
like maybe one other but you have to have a
really good four-wheel drive to do it it's
like look into it is called the white rim
Trail Moab it's a phenomenally amazing
mountain bike trip it's amazing and I can
even again he's when he's organized it
all right fine back to work back to work
you don't we can do what we could do like
art of the ex excursions like instead of
having like a conference or some shit you
can say hey everybody I'm going to be in
Moab for a week and you know right here I
can take the time off that's what's great
about being a contractor if you're a
contract as long as you let everybody know
and you're okay with not making money during
that week you can take the week off any time
but you have to have money you have the
money to do it hasn't yet and I'm delivering
balls and stuff it's one of the greatest
advantages of being a full-time employee
it was like it's off Clifton dude yeah
lesbian here drive 97 Ranger there you go
CS I think about this right now
and
I'm just going to say Rancho desktop was
announced last hour and let them do their
own searches of it that you're always a
four-wheel is it for is it for Ben Hur is it
for Banger I have for men with turbo
and it's going to get better gas mileage I'm
intrigued that shit out too and we got this
like this like Mooresville Subaru guy who
just like loves Ubers I'm totally going to
trick out my super I cannot wait anymore
money must work harder must work harder must
work faster
need money for Subaru it was weird we are
we're taking a break
we just lots of things are happening
I guess it's back to Rochester yes we are we
are not to just stop for now and I'm in
switch back to the provisioning for draining
nose which is boring but something I have to
do I'll be right back please please
let me see back
I should be back in about 5 minutes I'm like
right here God dammit
singledamn it
and again Texas Ranger
yeah all right so go install Rancher desktop
and tell me if you like it got it
that's your homework
God damn it I screwed up my thing and dammit
I just want to fire service in expectation
4A
yes
I'm going to leave this on the screen so
people can can fall out while I'm away
but you don't know when the five minutes
started do you if I missed could have
started ten minutes ago I don't know I don't
know we ain't nobody knows anything about
that wretched of stuff cuz nobody's tried it
yet I haven't
zelle
yeah I don't know it's going to be really
fast I hate the fact that it has a built-in
kubernetes that uses vm's instead of
and I don't know I didn't make you was going
to be you know what
I thought we could actually try that for
this task that we're doing right now is
going to use me to Q for it but I know I
don't know
so I mean should we go install it right now
why the hell not right
let's do that I'm wondering if we can
actually do this all flying task and kind of
test this out at the same time
why is this from Sousa
wait what did Susan by Rancher am I going to
sleep
even to the get a release when did that
happen holyshit I've been I've been out of
it I've been trying to keep up on The Last
Ship. It's so I used to spend an hour in the
news everyday
when did Susan by Rancher goddamn you know
what's interesting this is Microsoft
positioning
Microsoft has a huge stake in Souza it has a
huge stake in it
this is super interesting if if we have to
talk about this
Microsoft Souza relationship they like
control of it
I want to say there it is so disinterested
bility
made it on Panic, your pocket says listen to
it really threw me for a second Microsoft
Rancher ice what I'm saying
Susan is still pushing Microsoft proprietary
software the relationship between Susan
Heroes read this one this one trying to tell
you if you're new to this to this thing
why is it taking so long you have like a
virtual machine running or some shade
hey there's a Gemini version what the hell
David Gemini version
Gemini's that you know new text message
Nanette version it's not good but it's
better than sitting right right going to the
same as I have learned from the lessons
after the aftermath of navales the patent
scam just going to go shooting with this is
what when was this
I just doing 20
information about tonight's meeting as a
relationship with Microsoft Souza still
works closely with Microsoft
and it costly promotes us a proprietary
software is Q here
one of the developer advocates for sap is
one of our longtime community members we had
actually interviewed him about it
I like to hear guys that works for you
can I re kiss wrestler Emma I was afraid to
use the kids R Us
yeah that's actually not a bad thing God
damn it takes a long time to serve these up
Sousa to is becoming oval again
choose his own independent and make matters
worse it's helping Microsoft
I'm telling you yeah
I do see where the industry is going I mean
it's pretty obvious right
I feel like I feel like Microsoft is
come on Microsoft Champions itself as being
the leader of developers developers
developers tools if Microsoft actually pulls
this off
pause this song off and they integrate Susan
Rancher with of yourself to see everything
just works and they're going to have a solid
competitor against Docker entirely and
they've already got inroads against things
like openshift and stuff because they've got
it already got a counselor there all these
big Enterprise because Microsoft
I just tons of Microsoft shops because
Microsoft
that that's as receivers as a man and that's
not worth like guessing about
why should your financial Abs if the stores
are forever to do with the drive from
companies selling what type of ice cream
oh my God Susan actually did a Blog about it
I don't know
my favorite ice cream store is just it's
just off Richmond Green close to where I
live in London also need a local cues around
the block
geladas okay fine we're both OS agnostics
Asuza percent of us to Monday no problem I
have you been a redhead customer for dick
into want to play it and that's what you
will see the Rancho understand organizations
use to Saturday's on specific Linux distros
northerner take it you know what the money
is good and that's good because I like Ranch
her I really do I've always liked Rancher I
like the people at Rancher I like I mean
Corliss came out of Rancho right
Susan rental as we continue to respect his
decision because we're focused on the things
on
yeah I'm with infrastructure agnostic
pictures of some of them for treating cloud
yeah Rancho Vicky's real see you soon as I
heard it I knew it was based on case with us
and if people and people tell me all the
time that you should use k3s or Michael
Cates instead of a 3DS is that it's it's
it's not it's an edge kubernetes distro so
it's I don't know how real it's going to be
but it's going to be no less real than kind
romantic you probably right I mean and then
they could go to a real cluster then you got
to do a big red thing on music loud
so
interesting news to me today I found out
that Susan acquired I got to add a note here
for myself
is that crate did not know Sousa
acquired
fuck
news about
wow
I just need to put that in my in my notes
I don't need any more all right
I did something wrong you shouldn't have new
you shouldn't have that
I shouldn't have that worst performance
depends what you're doing is what you're
doing but yeah go is way faster than python
on every front
vanilla can raise a micro Gates kind of like
a 3s will because it's been on the edge as a
full thing right as an independent thing hbm
each whatever machine
I kind of know what it kind of makes me want
to install k3s into my as a distro generally
mean
in fact is there is there already a Linux
distro that does k3s
I don't I don't know I don't I don't know
Que Sera Sera
now I'm kind of thinking I might want to
duplicate 30s as my is on my Mac
you know yeah kiss your ass yes all that. I
knew but the question I have is
if that would be better for a bigger
deployment as well I've been feeling it
might be
Advance Auto cuz I mean if I need to do
things like texting too fast on the road. I
mean that's right of that big one or
something things like it is you can say hey
I want this OS and I want to try this and I
want to so stressed and right now I need to
recreate my current system and not in some
extra thing at their favor for
demonstrations about how to
you know about about how to get to do those
go back to off lining everything that's the
task for that does the task at hand
so back to what it says in the title
all right sweetie crates in pods and you
create a number of nodes three nodes
for serious work I agree
I agree and any any any time you leaving to
write storage classes and stuff like that
right you kind of need to know how to do all
of them and it's bad enough knowing how to
do one but it won't all
I have a Destiny is Big Ranch yard because
the Retro Windows it was promoted oh well
wishes for Friday and on you it's not the
same thing that was it
ha anyway all right so let's do let's do
this
I want to know it's it's running all the
pods
shut restart
restart the node maclear to known
and bring it back into the cluster
monitor that everything
gets distributed properly
or time it's a pretty easy task to do I just
want to do it really fast
at the edge yeah
watching his twin sheets were absolutely
absolutely
so serious work
I know it is I know it is for serious work
and it's kind of tiny in awesome so it's why
I'm talking about
at the edge usually means while processing
power but it also means a bunch of
point-of-sale nodes in inside a Lowe's
hardware store right
that's what's kind of any Edge got lots of
meetings is right
the edges hey I have is I have a single
server on site with my retail outlet and I
have a bunch of points sell computers and
they're all phoning home to my internal
carre's cluster which in turn phones home to
some master cluster instead of having a ton
of you know modem connections
yeah you didn't you like retail it
which is great because the edge like that
means that your your your entire company can
still work even if your internet connection
to your Upstream goes down or your buttons
don't work and not going to think they can
take credit card transactions that way
though so it's kind of weird I don't know
how that's ever going to ship I don't have a
lot of experience in retail lie to you but
Missouri till it but I do know a little bit
about it
Lowe's is headquartered here so I know I've
known people over the years that work there
instructions are given a standout in a room
in the store displays are locally yeah
that's exactly what I was talking about for
us right that's a fantastic example thank
you for that is a fantastic example when
people say. He's on the edge that's one of
the core meanings of it another one is in a
bunch of tiny devices or using kubernetes on
it on a on a martian Rover so that
everything is all covered entities by all
the sensors are all independent and they're
reporting home to a central brain within the
same you know tiny tiny thing and collection
tiny things
addition automation pipeline yep
on address and animal Razorbacks running
back well that's my theory on that is is
it's a lot of the people are doing sensors
stuff right so the more complicated
applications they have multiple sensors with
multiple independent systems and some people
can develop independent systems that use the
sensors of that device or whatever and then
they had rather than just having and then
they have more redundancies and stuff like
that so they can get all the same kind of
creators redundancies on like a robot that's
got multiple things from him you know a ten
each one of the sensor kind of knows would
be it would be would be a note and then you
can have it redone to see that way so
but I don't know I don't know that's that's
what I've heard
yeah that's that's what I think that's what
the edge means bottom line is you don't
assume you have it's kind of like offline
first and web development you never you
never trust that you have an internet
connection dude you can do some crazy shit
with Progressive web apps using offline
first you can have an app run entirely
without any access to the internet using
service workers is so cool
all right so what am I doing back to this I
need to get I need to get a server
and I think I'm going to go ahead and make a
I have to remember how to do multiple nose
and kind not kind in mini Cube I think I
could just do Notes 3 knows from the command
line
thank you I know it's funny I don't I don't
I go back in for 30 minutes even kind of
can't remember them both
YouTube create no it's not start yeah
start Dash p
well I mean if we do it like this is can use
a darker driver
note off
HD virtualbox
I'm going to have to tell at 3 now it's I
think I have to use a configuration file for
them
yeah when I deliberately didn't put corn and
rain in there on purpose because I don't I
want the I want the lab to read like a I
need to take my nose off safely how do I do
it and they don't know the term corn and
Rain yet that's why I didn't use it
because I want the challenge to be hey you
need to know what these things are called
and stuff I didn't want to give him too many
hints for myself this is making it into the
lab you know here's what you're being us to
do
this would work for like testing yourself or
somebody else
which I can't remember how to do this to
create multi node
cluster with mini Cube there's like there's
like Yahoo files for this I just don't
remember it
Monsuno there it is notes is it dashed knows
is that it fuc
I feel I feel bad yeah
I always put my commands in here because I
want to be able to remember them
minikube start Dash p I've known
test note off test
note off lab Dash
dash nodes we want to note so they give us
three total things
and fuck I should be it build
this is going to use Docker goddamnit I
didn't want to use docker
I guess I can use the car so I can be many
keys are for the Falls now if it finds
darker on your system uses darker instead of
instead of her Suboxone whatever
ruins your day I'm going to offline yes
yes please throw a ton of wrenches into my
day
yep I'm going to create a bunch of Damon
sets and shit on there that I unscrew
hoonigan statefulset I really want to see
what it does with the staple said
it's about as long as it is but I don't know
if
anywhere to find out I'm going to simulate
this you know this way
doing doctor like that provision like that
is like way faster than anything else
I don't know if you can do this what kind I
wish I would have kind of it even though I
don't know I don't know
what are the reasons I want to do this as I
want to I want to see if it leaves behind
like container ship
and when you use Mini Cooper kind you don't
get the container you can get the bar logs
container stuff because it's using it it's
using the container and I don't actually I
wanted you to be among us
I want us to be honest cuz it's not real
at the part of our flying part of the
problem with our planning stuff like I want
to practice Viola pull of plug if you pull a
plug out you leave a bunch of shit bunch of
container overlays around and you have to
clean that shit up and if you don't know if
we've had this problem before so you can't
really test that with a Docker container
because doctor is doesn't do any of that
storage stuff
I mean it does but it's using your
underlying system will release you have to
fill that thing I want to make sure
Custer of virtual machines just make sure
not using docker
and emulation yeah I don't feel comfortable
with that being a real test
I'm a doctor down that no
make you delete a speed test
when I call okay get clusters
I can't remember
what is it gets a I do remember
status of status of stars
make a profile has that's what I want I
forgot
oh shit we got a lot of other ones are too
MK delete clean
that's being a load goodbye
nice bicycle Go lessons
did you two do I have a another one for this
but I I added
alright so we got closer there is this a
or nothing 08
right driver Dash D
I can probably delivered but whatever damn
it
what are we doing let's use
all right we have
come on where are you is it that shot driver
if it is
then I have are you going to make me write
it out fine Minnie Driver
Builder let me make just need a script
two CPUs and to wish GB how come it's 220 as
weird
20 MB of disk holyshit I got 20 gig
hey Rich love you all of you going to be the
same
it should only do two CPUs on the first one
I've ever got to make a config file if I
wanted to use smaller than that
but whatever I can take a lot longer for
some books yeah
are you trying to go get some food
oh that Isabel kit bug
yeah okay yeah that's that's that we have
that
hey team I can't get notes
but I come out what the hell
exit again stretching what
shit can you give us any of the cast of yam
that's weird I haven't seen that before
semi truck repair in five or software
I mean
I don't have a firewall
why would that be
that's very odd building a network
how do I say
as I am looking for 22 on 118 Washingtonian
Boulevard
everytime I can recognize you
what is like a standard versabox problem
I want a bigger it made everything that by
default I know
I don't know I want to fuck with this cuz I
do not have time
but almost I was off what
what the hell I started one
what is the meaning of life
what what's the Nickelodeon by default Amino
I guess it's route IPA
isn't one when I come in 68 and 199 this is
totally fine what's the problem
all right well
haha
that would be a big ol no can't get to it
what is fucking up my routing
and that's that's the first time I've had
that problem that is obviously there
I don't have is you have is DFW different
thing right
you know I think I might have installed it
yes I do I do I turned off firewall D and
now I have you if I want to think
is that an a bunch of thing is federal d a a
redhead thing and you have w a bunch of
thing
I am okay I need I need to make a thing
about that
is Ivan and I haven't been in for a while
and for much firewalls it 12
I'm coming yeah I knew about that one myself
for awhile. I was confused because that's a
red hat thing
apparently you have w
is The Omen 2 equivalent
of firewall D on red hat
it is active yes it's definitely active so
it would turn off right now and and all
things will be fine and that actually
explains a lot
explains a lot just disabled yep
so that I learned something today so yeah it
wasn't there so I just needed to disable
that's now I don't know when that was added
to tell you the truth
I think it might be the default I should be
able to SSH. No problem
or not
and yes I love you status
okay fine I suggested it could have been
running
could have been running but still an active
I see you're saying I didn't check that
yeah I was going to say I've never had a
problem with me to get for this not once
I have never had a problem I've used me to
keep a ton and I've never had this problem
before course I never use mini cube with
virtualbox is a percent of usable box
as so apparently doesn't get to it so you
know who knows
cluster
I do find it odd that it actually made a
virtual it didn't clean it up
Sirius using look at the network immigration
yeah where did that did we not I mean
is it a zero is on $10 or 0 to 200 isn't we
always doing the same thing again
I seen the same netted primary interface
shit again it's all I wanted to know when
it's 1:10
is it that makes me think that
I don't know what that makes you think that
is me to keep using favorites in full stuff
up
or is it that there's a big difference of
boxes to Fallsington out on everything is
automatically making everything that'd I'd
maybe it's a virtualbox setting for Nat by
default
and that's why the primary interface is it
the same problem you're having a better day
with the bigger stuff and 80 is by default
this you know other other thing
I think that this is actually a I control
what's the h I didn't mean to power the
machine off God damn it
but I guess it's off now
yeah not say that
it's billing stuff not as a default and I
feel like there's some default setting
yeah that's what you so silly I just like
the other ones we've had
and I love you. We've had this before so
that means this makes me think
but I would really like there's some bucks
only make one network interface
I'm starting to think that I've used for
some box before and it only has one I
already looked at that we didn't already
that's the one I need to address
and I can look again but the thing I want to
do is I want to get virtualbox to make stuff
that only has one adapter
add I did already we talked about
a network configuration I'm of what a mini
Cube or of
on a machine
has Anarchy figuration Avenue is it
in the menu five and this isn't there's some
default for virtualbox
host network manager
there we go there we go
host network manager so these are the
different workers that works at H creating
for everything and this stuff was probably
created with acorns
yeah that's what's going on all right
yes of course I've seen that I am never mess
with a number to monitor before
yeah it doesn't find I would rather prefer
Messi address
are you here but why is making two adapters
at 20%
he doesn't have nothing I got a few yeah
I sent her face
I'm just trying to think every surf we
Hale Community one
let me see there's another Network layer and
there's some sort of there's some sort of
firewall in your dad and going on inside of
her two boxes killing Elsa never had that
problem
I'm going to search for here I'm going to
give you an yeah I'm almost positive you can
yeah let's bring it up again
I rent a room in and out a toboggan it's in
that
send that when is 11 was not going to
support virtualbox and then I tried it and
it worked it was like from 2,000 121 super
happy that that was not true
I mean him
it was impossible to see I realize I'm sorry
so everything you were paying
90 route 168 1
well can you get to the router
yeah that would have been where they didn't
block it that they did look it actually it
was because they said they were going to
drop their restrictions on on security and
stuff and so it effectively eliminated it
from the list of stuff that supports Windows
there's no router and that's that's kind of
kind of bad XVI
all these extra volumes audition I'm not
used to doing that a lot
inconvenience in at 1
Estes Park Tramway Center
so interested yeah I would love to see if I
can find out to be really surprised if it's
Florida
I drew out show yeah this is not stuff I do
everyday
is it fall Trout's condemned it's tiny how
can I zoom in
I can probably turn the phone. Scale mode
oh God Chrissy. Better
I think I'm going to bring some over some
more better if such better graphics support
I need the results are yeah
that's exactly what it was and I hope cuz I
want to try it I want to try when it's 11
today or the other day and it works so it
wasn't it wasn't it has the same issue so I
figure out what surrounds I think it's the
whole default route issue again
Define annoying I mean I don't know we're
going to find out huh
network operations manager you're not Active
network operations
so
yes it was just nice it is nice that it does
that
I like I found it is I'm going to go do a
little search on this
I'm going to look for this air again and
after the thing
damn it that's not good stuff should be an
issue this is for suboxone supposed to just
work
so if anything doesn't work because of
something else is going on
is an alternative VM driver
restart the restart wait did I not do as a
virtual machine driver
restart restart or reinstall virtualbox I
mean that might be the problem
on your house you might flash your public IP
he's not I don't use that I don't give a
shit
it's the 171 I'm not drunk that internet
as much as shit on here and we have a lot of
stuff on here
you know if I want 17 address digital
internal though
I got so much shit in here and look at all
these Bridges I should probably go I read
this is why you should because of you cuz I
I should probably just read redo this
machine
I can't be all down
any boxing that stuff
and I don't why are they down there not down
I didn't take him down
I didn't take him down there listed is up on
me on virtualbox
so what's up with that anymore
how the ship how did they get taken down we
pumped up them then we done
poison ivy I can pick up I remember
yeah
well that's a different that's a different
command than I used to use I've realized
that you like 20 up
what do I have a good down though maybe it
maybe it didn't have didn't have them
key locks State up
2 2 2 2 2
nope eyes of the IP change
oh right because it might have grabbed a new
one from dsv
if you have a night
so that's the underlying interface to the
virtual machine with that directly change
the Russian machines IP address
I mean I would seem really weird to me yeah
I've had one of those two dead box
it's just another route why are we why are
we adding another Alto
is that I can't because it we didn't die at
CP it because mr. to step right now it's
right it's this s e run from the other
scripts to pull and pull down the days of
the address yeah I see what you're saying
it's up
it's up we just added have an IP yeah I
seriously okay yeah this is the stuff that
the description we take care of for you
right okay yeah I haven't years I haven't
set up my own stuff yeah
192.168 I have a feeling if I restarted for
suboxone clean everything up it would just
work so I don't want to be Leah confused
here
I'm not used to yeah so
he walks up yet every l
and should be able to bring it now yet an
SSH to it
yah yay yay team
at and then I can do there's no password
password less
I don't know password dude I was on the
terminal, so that's why
yeah it's not going to allow that
it's not because I didn't want to terminal
this is as remote As to associate has
probably got to see this really is it
what
the two
yeah anyway so well because we brought the
interface up
it was a thing as soon as you can because we
brought the interface up in the host system
so that means that the virtualbox
network interface should be configured
properly for when I do this
I'll look at gave it to it wait that wasn't
there before or was it
but I don't get that me this this
play the Spider-Man surprise anymore by the
rabbit hole which rabbit hole
yeah I don't have those all the time so so
this one
yep this one is the thing I understand is
that these things are here
this is an adapter issue
is it a host adapter
yeah right I'm tempted to just take out the
Birchbox manager is it reinstalled and I
have noticed so that when I install
uninstall verse about sometimes it leaves
around networks network interfaces and I
hate that I think it's a bug I think that's
a bug
yep anyway we'll give it a shot that's all.
Play or stop close power off
I think there is but I don't know it
I got to stand I don't I usually don't deal
in this much with virtual machine this is
been a lot of I've been doing doctor for
last year and a half so I do all my stuff
inside rocker and I think I went to Great
Lengths to stimulate workstations and nose
and doctor and so this is going back to
Mercer machines is a totally different thing
because you have to manage on your faces and
volumes and everything so it's so you got to
know it
and all these things are off a date you know
the stuff that they've created might be part
of the problem
what I'm going to give again
hip alright so
they're going to allocate all that again
what's inside
all fun stuff and if
and it gets messy though cuz you get you get
so many virtual interfaces doctor creates
its own interfaces and the overlays
everything it makes your whole system like
we should you kind of wish has some point
that your whole system was was a virtual
machine
but then you can't have a virtual machine
inside a machine unless you're using my
clippers something I mean keep her
yeah
this is one of the reasons to that you
should kind of get used to reimage in your
system all the time and as Doctor Professor
would love to hear me say you should
probably not be streaming from the same
system because then you know I can fucking
around on another system and then just have
the video piped-in through capture card and
then you know you guys can see it the
problem with that is
that you know I have to switch keyboards to
do that a lot and I don't want to
hey look at works because it has an
interface
I know that already exists as much as I do
configure want versus box driver warning
it's like there's a driver there are there
options for better performance to support
use KVM to nope
is my credit one node which annoys me
Irvington Raceway but it's the first time
I've ever
and those primary will be ignored the
cluster node off lab already exists
no dad dad knows an existing cluster what
it doesn't make any sense any human being
weird
I guess it just did a control plane yeah
Espeon ode
all right now we're on here with their user
ID
Docker how do we darker oh I know I know
I've never mind
nevermind
far no Etsy
container
retainers that's a Saturday
config. Tell Mall 38
that's cool so you can learn a lot by the
how they can figure there's
key rhenium there is no cure ATM and they
said it was configured with your video and
now there's a video
I don't know if I believe him and then I
keep CDL over here
Cuba NM
I'm thinking I lied I read somewhere that it
they said me to give us configure Wikipedia
Missouri I don't believe it for a second
1 times something about Ms
yeah I'm going to need more evidence of that
so
I don't I don't know if it's looking for a
time that Ms or not
yeah dude Benchmark that let us know so
I'm not convinced this is going to be any
any easier
I don't know I kind of want to say going for
this cuz I don't know I don't know and I
don't get my getting warm fuzzies
no offsets
running configured
I don't know. Maybe I would actually do
something more specific
yeah I wouldn't I would use something like
hyper what's it called
No I can't remember the name of it
there's a bunch of like bench markers out
there it stopped this from one of the best
oh hey how's it going Kelly thank you for
the Patriots
let me see here we can do
I really really don't want to have to do
this separately but I'm going to do it
that's pee
I know note off lab but I want no dad
all right sending us a new node
I wonder what I wonder what Robertson Box is
doing we should probably check
hey. I have no. 5 in 02 is now running
so note to self if you see many give you
have to have multiple commands
a app that multiple commands
descendants 1
takes a lot longer I was going to run slow
or make big made a big complaint saying hey
we don't think you should do this you know
make him sad want Russian box driving
warranty as I'd rather not have that thank
you very much
let's stare at another one what's up
personification really ironic
I don't know what happened to the adapter I
can't imagine what would have changed on
that though you know
and it could have been any number of things
we've been fucking around virtualbox all
along you know
I'm learning a lot about virtualbox volumes
and interfaces though so that's good might
had no idea that you can add a virtual box
in her face and then manipulated directly on
your house computer but it makes total sense
I just never had a need to do that before
which means I need to get back into a
network interface Administration test and
learn all that shit all over again I I I did
it a long time ago to set up my own routes
and everything was one time but I can't you
know it's all changed its all-new you can't
really do for structure engineering without
knowing how to do that though you got to be
able to check your network stuff and
everything so
I see you don't really need any compounds
now I'm at a cloud
I'm all about one friend that's what I do at
work and so I don't really care about
Clinton that the truth is is it called if
you learn the 7 learning applies to Cloud
it's like Cloud plus so if I ever need to do
Cloud I just had to use the interfaces for
cotton figure it out but I'm more of a
non-friend person so I'm speaking which I
want a find the best on friend Cloud
software that's not openstack
and that's actually something I'm seeking
because I have a bunch of machines I want to
make my own cloud at home and then you start
for Monett stuff like that so I'm looking
for that for
I'm looking for that for about proxmox and a
number of others so that's something I've
been researching
you do need to do to be a me didn't you
didn't you do the cluster for me to keep
oh Ray Wright thanks for the reminder
everything yeah
how's it going at 11 so so we are off and
running
we're at the races
I can't get Noah's we should get a bunch of
notes are there we go this is what we're
doing
I'm running pop OS but I don't really like
it
I've been running for a while and it runs my
winter and and and you know and Dota 2 in
TF2 and all that so I've been keeping it for
now but I'm going to boot it eventually
I can't find a sitter start screaming for my
Mac and then use the current yes, she
neither is a gaming rig which is what it
actually is or and I can put Windows on
there and then get another server and
provision I think I don't know that
approximates everybody's been saying proxmox
proxmox give you fight at home and I want to
do it and I want to add a bunch of machines
have my proxmox and speak I don't have none
that have a have a no no rabbit holes
I'm working I got it I got to focus and I
almost getting hungry so that's the coffee
small
what are we doing here what are we doing
wrong so
all right you know what for giggles and
grins I'm actually going to listen to take
time but I I would rather do this
I'm going to oh shit what are you sending me
Brioni more sidetracks
oh God
when did this happen you telling me he got
hacked
he didn't get hacked or did you do it
I think somebody's making fun of him right
I don't know how to raise if I could have
one can I read Harry commits under you are
proud of your l
anybody describing how to install I just saw
him our voices can be under your name
as as if you made the command
holy shit this is huge this is huge
no wonder you should sign your commits huge
that's a perfect that's a perfect lesson
right there
yeah
that is amazing
this is a commit that wasn't signed right
did he actually did he actually break the
tree with this
I think it did that's not a branch how does
he even have access to do that
all Torvalds didn't do this Diddy there
wasn't make that post
thorvaldsen make that post
yeah wow
I mean how does he even get to claim it soon
it didn't have to get home
it's just an unsigned commits
security is not associated with a repo wow
to to do
wow
that's the same one thanks me too cute yes
nobody knows how to sign him I'm just going
to teach people gpg in the Moose god dammit
thank you for that
nobody wants to learn as a stage 1 lung gpg
we're never going to be done whenever
I'm deleting the same building in the end
because I don't trust it so
El Amor H added to get to her yeah
x-ray it's not that hard it yeah I mean I'm
thinking about doing with 11 year olds right
so and yes they can do it but it's like one
extra thing
and I can tell you what I'm just I like to
think of your things and you know Baseline
rule
are you Cube delete Dash p
no off while I'm deleting the whole Lab and
I'm going to add another one
because I want to do this is because I want
to build all three at the same time and I
don't think I should have to do them
individually
Nelson doesn't show up and told her I was
giving history so he has no idea block fuck
that is like something to learn how to do hi
chef I really want to learn how to do that
I want to learn how to do that
why is Netgear sending me advertisements for
entities oh my God what is the world coming
to
oh my God this is insane
I hate snacks okay what are we doing in case
you just join us we're building
we're we're trying to
do the very basic task six pack in his teeth
no variation it's again
Antoinette mother beer belly one without the
Reveille
I got it I got it
I'm at a surf don't get that six-pack back
that's not here now it's been like if you
can see the scale of
you can see the scale of like technical
skill and physical health should be like
this
psych psych psych undulating wave
like my skills in the last week and a half
is like skyrocketed through the roof with
technology because of the stuff he's been
doing
but so has my waistline it's cuz I have not
been doing any exercise at all
I know it's like
I told her I thought it said look at this
look at this beer belly hurts cuz yes but
think about your brain where is your brain
right now and then we had sex
that's fine girls like smart people too by
the way
I just want my support on making I'm making
Point promise
the point is smexy yes you can
you know it got to work both sides of it in
a little bit I know too much information I
know it's for you and you're you're you're
you're German sensibilities I'm so sorry
Moser what should I tell you why are you
serious about to settle KVM to drive
everywhere
because kbm
I love gave you my lover lover to get all
the work and everything I've been using
virtualbox for this Elsa want to be able to
have visibility into it and I know I can do
this with the manager and all that stuff
right
right now I'm seeking commonality across
operating systems more than I'm seeking
because this is the method of doing this I
want people to be able to do anywhere right
that's the main reason today and despite all
its quirks and slowness and everything
virtualbox is far more cross-platform
compatible than all the other ones I found
out the other day on Mack and stuff but
I don't know if I would if I would sell them
oh it only added one
is it because I said to nodes I didn't think
I was kidding did it how's it going
yeah I'm definitely your knee came out of
that
Miami macaroni suddenly yeah we found that
out who are You the One recording reporting
that yesterday
yeah I don't know if it ever will be you
know
I see what's up yes
yeah I thought I thought the control plane
was included obviously it's not so we're
going to do this
I did what I was wanting it to do though so
we're good to go 73 notes are next time so
that we can do
I make you
no dad that's pee test
there's also a shoebox regional manager gave
him the yeah I know I've been using a ton of
the whole thing for a full week like a week
ago and I don't know what I came to do and I
was doing all the thing and play around with
the liver provider for terraform and ansible
and vagrants and we got all that working and
everything and and then I was really
weighing it against
you know how is this going to be Universal.
I mean I think it's good to learn that it's
just very specific I feel like a lot of the
stuff has been based on Boost decisions
which are going to be for beginners and
teaching beginners first I think is not an
optimal choice I think you should teach
beginners virtualbox first assuming it's
going to run a Mac it if it doesn't it's why
I was checking out the other stuff there's
lots of uses for virtual machines and
involve a lot of it
but this wretched episode it is did you
dress it Victor did you test it for sure
can you please talk about that specifically
yeah if you're doing that
oh my God that is I got to put on my notes I
got to put in my notes send my notes
wow
and that is that super duper huge
the reason I'm pausing is because if I want
to do I've been trying to make decisions
about how to get people that Unix Linux
command line the fastest for the Boost and
boost in 2021 I tried Docker desktop and it
really tremendously well the downside of it
obviously was it you know it was a femoral
we had to show him how to reattach and all
that stuff but made it was good because all
the extra effort to to reinstall Andre app
and saw everything I think worked well yeah
I know that's if Victor it's wet and So
based on this discovery today I do not want
to leave and One max out of the boost on May
4th
and I think the information that you've just
reported may be enough to have me switch
over to rent or desktop as the basis for the
beginner boost to get a Linux terminal in
the fastest way possible
otherwise I feel like this might be the main
way to do that and if you just download the
binary and it just works I mean that's
fucking crazy amazing easy easy peasy kind
of stuff for beginners to do so again the
reason I have a beginner boost every year
and the reason I redo the content every year
is because the tech industry changes the
tooling changes so quickly
and I know yes yesterday I would have big
long fucking post about why we should use
virtualbox and learn DM's right
I'm like I am so torn
get that let them is be real here this is
primary thing that promoted me to use
virtualbox over over again was vagrant and I
was about to throw bait or not the window
because it's so old and busted and uses for
being used as a liver it was a pain in the
ass to get going and most of vagrant is is
is Neo Taylor 2/2 box give me a virtual
boxer slow and horrible and I had slowed
down my my stuff when I switched over to bet
it was primarily vagrant that set that 4 and
then at that led me to think hey we need to
have a we need to have a virtual box systems
so people can try out different distros
yeah doctor easy solutions the problem with
the doctor easy solution I know we can make
it work as we did last week last last year
does not use doctor absolutely no no they do
not use docker
it's fully doctor compatible but it doesn't
use doctor I mean you can make an alias for
an urgency to yell or whatever and use
Docker and said
yeah it has a doctor yeah so
I need the lightest-weight best way to get a
Linux command line is darker on the desktop
hands down. Hands down it take s to install
Docker desktop or its replacement Rancher
desktop and it takes 10 minutes to get Linux
up and running on it just like that you
don't have to download I supposed to have to
install anything it's just works it get you
and by the way it doesn't come with a lot of
extra shift so you have to add it and adding
the stuff helps you learn how to use the
terminal and we had fantastic success with
that last year
but all this stuff about all this reminder
recently about using
okay the other primary driver for using
virtualbox was that people could test out
desktop Linux distros and arrived at 1 that
they want to use but here's the deal I'm
about to throw up Linux on the desktop
myself
because I don't give a shit I want I want I
want Linux in my
clinics in my containers that I would Linux
on my service I could give a shit about
having Linux on my desktop it doesn't give
me anything extra at all it doesn't it gives
me the opportunity to strip things but I can
do all that from Sun container or a VM or
whatever my point is is I don't need it I
don't need it on my desktop and that's
that's like me I'm a big person but to say
that you don't need it
what I want to know is if that conflicts
with the Bissell 2x anybody test that we
need somebody I need to go to that we need
to go test whether doctor weather Rancho
desktop will work on
we need WeatherBug working a double cell
enable system protector that's got any
connect from from Cisco VPN because that's
the thing that doesn't work for me right now
yeah you decide what is a Rancher just
stopped using her to jail or doctor owe you
can't you can do the doctor
you can do docker
if you do the darker does that give you
access to the docker Hub and everything cuz
I kind of want to kick people off Docker Hub
but it's just so easy to use it so I don't
know if you know
anyway this is like really thrown my
conclusions about switching to a virtual
machine in the air I really have to say and
I'm actually going to post a link to those
to those things right now
is that link
so I guess not
when does risen box fails to boot extra
driver serving abroad
see this
running on a surprise that requires episode
2 holyshit
it is still standing still too but
automatically oh my God you would have pain
in the ass it is getting kids to install
them in SO2
that's fucking insane let me just going to
configure properly and everything okay so
the only thing that we have to test on that
is to make sure it works with anyconnect VPN
if if a container running inside of it uses
anyconnect VPN because it breaks and it
works properly we are fucking golden I mean
that it's like massive news that is really
great news
all right if if that works then I don't want
to use anything else ever and I want to
start everybody on it like immediately
because they can take that with them they
can do mediately to doctor they can do to
bring at least another two more terminal
skills that they could ever want they could
create a femoral containers that also
Mountain you know dislike we're going to
like it in the in the thing so they can have
their files and not lose them they can make
sure you say, get everything and then they
can learn virtualization later during
infrastructure engineering boost and at that
point as I've said I'm not really married to
Virgil McEver the thing that like there's
two primary drivers for virtualbox I'm going
to let me go through
and I I'm kind of annoyed by this this is
Versa vice versa Boxster wish you were doing
right now so I'm about ready to throw it out
and just gave him to his why the fuck are we
using for some box I mean really I'm
listening to what you have to say here's my
primary motive is this is what got me to
change my mind where's the Vox just hurts
everywhere it well it kind of doesn't write
is also really slow right but that
this is this is a lie this is a lie I'm
going to put an update in here
I work on M1 Max
and has been known to not be supported on
Windows 11 in the past
questioning this conclusion he's conclusions
I sure desktops is out
x86 system yes
but I don't want that look so so my criteria
for picking a best personal experience has
been
I can you send anywhere I can you know you's
gooeys
allows for safe experimentation I want to
try ten different Linux distros were two
boxes the only way to deal with the pain and
suffering
right where's the Box machines have
persistent state
so does the other things that's it this is a
big plus / containers for beginners
beginners get burned by the ephemeral nature
of containers all the time but it's actually
a good thing because it because then they
have to learn how to mount discs in and use
GitHub and stuff like that and they can
learn to detach and reattach it's not a
problem it's all I know what happens if they
wipe out the containers so glass and 2021 we
did it fine because we didn't teach him how
to delete their containers in your container
and then they would reattach that container
and start it back up and it was persistent
it was only it was evidently died when you
deleted the container with you in dark we
have to do explicitly so I still think we're
okay there are some box machines have a
persistent say what type of that virtual box
machine images of real as this true this is
true we don't get this slimmed-down version
so I'm fatter right where's the box has been
the primary driver for vagrant yeah but if
we can get around vagrant
who gives a shit there's a box of the
command line and lightweight images this is
true
it does you can use for tomorrow in the
command line to talk to things I just hope
his fryer suffer any longer for your
business. You're just a bit but this is just
been deflated do this is one of the main
reasons and now we have rent. Thanks for
services can run Docker this is true and
Lennox person who she's going to doctor
Windows Virtual machines cannot I cannot
imagine having somebody run Dr inside a pop
OS running inside of a VM
average of boxes better driver than Mini
Cooper darker
no it's not even that many people now the
fall doctor if detected it makes a little
sense to do it kind that's not does Doctor
container such things now it's not a fast
we're going to just give him two for them so
that that third that third piece of evidence
is to me hey how's it going thank you for
the sub I send me that and that is
this M1 Mac support thing is huge to me
all right so so as of this moment I have to
test it still I'm almost concluded that we
are going to use ranch or desktop for for
2020 and I just told everybody yesterday
when they own thing that goes over to box
and then he was like I can't function just
over two bucks and I'm like no go install
something like why are you changing your
mind so much is it going to just fucking
came out and it's the tech industry get
fucking used to it
I hate taking a shit for changing my mind
2022 in it
2021 Bruce Willis doctor desktop 2022 we're
going to use
and as of this moment we're going to answer
this job just for the M1 support if for no
other reason that we're ever going to try it
or is it going to try it
did I say 2020 I meant 24:1
did I change my mind all the time and I
can't ship for it constantly from people
that know me I'm like welcome to the tech
industry
I don't know how many times I go back and
forth between get home and get lab
there's there's compelling reasons you have
to make it all you got to have a cruise this
year
Sapphire 20 20 20 20 20 20 20 to boost will
as of this moment I'm going to test it up
till yesterday or just now we can use
virtualbox so now we're going to
here's a real thing though how how much how
much do I really give a shit about helping
people test their Linux out there desktop
Linux distro
and I barely saw it on this particular point
I'll I don't give a shit about desktop Linux
I really don't and you know what I love it
and it there's a lot of reasons I I like it
but I'm not as long as I have a good Docker
container deal with the work in someplace
I'm fine and I get work done plenty good
that way and I've been told it you know if
you pee in some of those downloading why do
you keep downloading things like that run
under McCraw or Windows raw so if that works
and I why do I even need it
you know
so this is this is complicated for me this
is, and the words I am in the boots I may
actually be advocating to not protest doctor
on your desktop
I mean is 2022 the options the remote on
this particular with dr. I mean sorry with
with ranch or desktop now how's it going up
now I have to say very openly before chicken
with ranch or desktop. If you have your own
mini communities cluster and W still to
install fault and you have going on there
and and all you have to do is install
Windows 10 on what you have to do with
Windows little bit with whatever you got
everything you need you don't you do if that
turns out to be true I need to validate that
right now we didn't is brand new and it came
out 2 hours ago if that turns out to be true
you do not need Linux on your desktop in
fact I cannot think of a single reason to
put Linux on your desktop other than the
regular you want you know Linux prawn in
full control and you want to edit out and
and mess with you no gnome is actually
pretty cool guy some pretty cool stuff in
her face is like that but other than that
why why why
and I'm going to tell me put a challenge out
there to the world strong toolkit fictions
loosely held I think I agree so this is
Cheryl. There's a very Devils out of it
challenge
why on Earth would you run Linux on your
desktop why
and I mean that I mean that I want people to
take me to TASC on this particular Point
Expo deck
it is raining right now and you feel
offended I'm not attacking you I'm asking
you a question why are you running Linux on
your desktop if it's a desktop reference
okay. Would be a very solid Point very sore
and I have very specific just a practice
course I live in the terminal so I don't
give a shit
a lot of UPS don't work with it okay that
would be doubly so too but but we
what I'm trying to tell you is one of the
ways to work around right now right now my
number one way to work around that wsl2
issue is to use Docker desktop
and I know it's a guaranteed easy way to get
around that issue because it Bridges the
network and that the thing I have right now
the number one thing I have to do this is
because if if Rancher desktop does the same
thing that darker does sub this with regard
to networking it will automatically bridge
to the VPN network and it will fix the issue
I'm trying to tell you is that ranch or
desktop could very potentially be the fix
for the anyconnect of yourself to issue
because it installs of yourself to as a part
of it this is all pie-in-the-sky I haven't
touched any of this yet but if this is true
then ran her desktop is literally the holy
grail for desktop for desktop Enterprise
Linux on Windows it's a holy fucking Grill
because it it will take care of all that
stuff
I can't install virtualbox on in my VPN I
can't at all I'm not even allowed to use it
at work I can't install it
I kind of someone is living in a said I'm
going I'm going to Lenox if Windows doesn't
want me okay what were some of the things
can you run Kali from USB yeah it's pretty
cool Kelly stuff like that would go he's
yeah I know that stuff I would be interested
to talk about you
all the stuff with gooey still works by the
way the end of yourself too right you know
you can use full Ghillie applications on
Windows you can use you can use x
applications on windows with them is so too
and they are 100% the same
I honestly just easier to manage apt in his
soul and all that stuff yeah but I mean all
the Snapchat that just happened I might be
on the Run for the Hills
and Iand I just share folders yes
cuz I have my Canon stuff when it's 11 and I
said I'm going on Lisa Quinn doesn't want me
that make sense that's a good reason to go
look I'm running now and I like the
flexibility and then really immediate
don't use it but still here immersive
learning is a reason to sawdust up Linux I
would be another good reason
that would be a good reason Elementary OS
that's one of the many ones I want to try
Elementary and it was of all the arch
distros is the one that I want to try the
most
yeah I haven't tried it I haven't tried it I
wait I could really cool I do like a really
really nice user interface doesn't mean I
want to trade support for my Sound
Engineering and and stuff like that I don't
know I have I tried my job and make brick
tile my machines in my lap and I hate it
I know right I normally that you just like I
like my voice to mine
until lately lately it's been degrading
Buffalo us is having really bad problems you
probably seen him my menu system is all
booked up they got rid of they got rid of
all tab performance the way it was working
before our enemy has four years when it says
offer more freedom for my job and learning
however I'm going to resend me the full
switch and still keeping my wages when she
forgave me yeah what a year. It's a whole
thing dude I don't want to do this in my
journal story right now. There's somewhere
of me talking about it but I'm lying to me
and a bunch of people in my lab clicked on
their graphic system upgrade tool and it
break the machine wouldn't do it anymore it
was a black screen and the hole in the
company just said oh you should have done
that you should have went into your extra
TTYL and I said click on this great tool I'm
like why the fuck is the upgrade to live
there and I went to my job because it was it
was heralded as really great easy to use
this room as a piece of shit and then when
people blew up nobody wanted to help them
and I know how to help him I've done letting
the building is pretty much from scratch in
the 90s and and I know how to do that but I
recommended this to begin with because it
was so easy to use and it turned out it
wasn't actually Chris Titus bursitis the SEC
he was he was one of my favorite people who
was the first that's how I found out about
him I watch this video and I had the same
problem like but I had to deal with it and I
had a guy actually cost me money because my
whole life was down I had to reboot and do
all kinds of hacking to get mice in my
system back I was pissed and then and then
he just went the other way and they try to
pretend like it never happened it was not an
issue was a major fucking issue was all over
Twitter is all over their support things and
then all of the Arch Linux heads came out
and attacked all the beginners that were
using mongeral and I was like I want to
fucking thing to do with this community at
all
and then they tried to sell Enterprise
software and sneak it into their distro and
they got caught doing that to their is shit
company the Montero company that Mojo
organization are criminals man they're
fucking I can't believe people even consider
it knowing what I know about them as a
company in organization now they're they're
worse than canonical by a long way like near
really bad
yeah I'm sorry if you don't like that if you
liked it fine you can use it you can I'm not
telling you not to use that I'm telling you
my experience to keep these over the years
so I can get to work. Tired of having to
worry about you he thinks you're tweaking
right
yeah most people say I haven't had an issue
there for your wrong and I'm like okay tell
that to the thousands of people that had an
issue when they broke everybody
telling him I didn't have an issue sound
problem I must be going to suck you must not
be a good Lennox person
it's the problem with my drawers it says
that it's just a really awesome happy distro
for beginners and then they go do that and
then they basically the flip off the whole
fucking beginner Community if I'm like okay
if that's how you want to be that's fine you
can choose to do that
yeah
yeah I'd ever is the one I would probably
try but yeah
yeah if it was a nice yeah I think it really
sucks about my jarrow is there were so many
people posting stuff you know they did they
flooded the Montreal company flooded their
Twitter feed with positive things about
Manjaro to make all the negative stuff go
away rather than address the negative stuff
they just started
they just started covering it up so that
nobody would know and they were trying to
manage perception and like keep their good
image everything else like you shit heads
they didn't even begin to try to own their
mistake they could have come out and said oh
hey we made a mistake in this one thing
we're really sorry they could have reached
out to people but they didn't they went the
other way and was soon as they did that I
didn't want anything to do with him ever and
ever
is the main reason ceremony right you need
to be better right try harder right
you don't look like they did a lot of people
yeah it was it was a whole cover-up thing
and I was right in the middle of it I was
right in the middle of it and I I don't like
reporting that that way I can make me get
angry
you are a prince all my fault by the way
their whole are you wash it it's green stamp
their whole whole thing to tell you that
they have a safe version of the aor that
they've been total bullshit it's absolute
bullshit it's perception management you know
why because I'm on General organization
wants to get their shit in the Enterprise
They want to be the first Arch Linux distro
to get in the Enterprise and they know they
won't come out of gold and red hat money and
they have been pushing for that for a long
time that's why they got us what a fuked up
with all the Enterprise though they are
specifically trying to Target their TurnKey
Enterprise Linux it's so that they can get
it behind the wall Garden in Forestville do
that and one of the ways they do that is say
so Enterprise people ciccio's you don't like
the way you are cuz it's too scary and it's
unfilled and it's like the wild west out
there you know what we're going to take care
of that for you we're going to fit all of
them and make sure they're nice spring and
cleaning and pretty and happy and then they
say they're going to do the beneteau they're
really doing is rubber-stamping all that
shit there just rubber
GoGo compare some of the packages all they
do is rubber stamp them and they put him
straight into they don't do any wedding at
did you go look at them to go look at their
history on their history of Security
Management to a company that's why I'm
calling criminals there fucking lying to
people telling them that they're trying to
make us safer distro and it's going to be
this and that and they want to get that
sweet sweet Enterprise money and so they
cover it all up and they advertise shit in
the sneaky Enterprise proprietary software
when it makes sense for them till they get
caught doing it and then they rubber-stamp a
bunch of Arc of that even fucking looking at
it because it's too much work to do it
do you know I don't want anything to do with
an organization like that and that is the
opposite of free and open source to me but
if you like there's their distro find go use
it I don't want anything to do with it
alright so
doing yeah they're marking is fucking
amazing right now yeah nobody knows any of
this I know and I meant I know I need to
watch that have I was I was kind of sad cuz
I love the way you know maybe it's just like
the true momentum behind arches is free and
open-source Linux that's what makes the are
you are so fucking amazing it's why the dead
man comes along and says hey let's do it to
you know I'm I'm totally on board with all
that and end the Arts Community isn't an
amazing Community when they're not you know
condescending assholes there are awesome
they're awesome they're promoting Lenox and
a great way they're making their do an NDA
or the idea of having an open you know
repository exchange even though it's unsafe
is great I love it it's like a gate you know
Janelle gatekeeping going on I love all of
the stuff is coming from the arch Community
which is why I find it so tragic that
Montero has
marketed themselves into something that they
think is the best version of that and I
don't think I used it all the time for
different things up
so I look that we can you tell why I don't
tell that story very often
the reason I don't tell that story very
often is because I just it makes me upset
and it was my where's my plushie give me my
plushie
I don't talk because it makes me sad the
story makes me sad people get upset they
feel like there are bubbles or burst and I
just ended and now people get upset right
yeah and because you've been lied to and the
thing is is you don't even know even like
you and if you start to ask them about how
you been lied to do so I don't know what
you're talking about because they covered it
all up I hope some of those forms are still
out there
yeah it's if I had to live through it but
you got to understand it was I had married
Munroe I was so excited about it I was
legitimately excited somebody told me about
an hour with this acquisition and I got
and I got so into it and I was helping
everybody use it and I was I was champing it
I was an evangelist and get it and then that
shit went down and I just I was I feel like
my heart has been ripped out I did I don't
like that I don't like that and I don't like
telling people about it I know it's like
it's like telling people you know it's like
ripping down someone's religion the others
know Jesus right there's no Santa there's no
Easter Bunny there's no cheese
and Montrose a bunch of criminals
he's going to come after me of this season
this is saying stop calling us criminals we
haven't done any crimes okay fine they're
not criminals how about that I make a
retraction Banjara is not criminals there
just liars
how about that is that better
oh I just discovered something new
if you run if you run from Aziz ears she
makes noise
she has she has buttons in her ears I can
feel
Mozzy Mozzy just became a girl just like
right then
I don't want to read it cured me for my
Manjaro story it totally worked this is
totally threw me from a madrone tree versus
a box I think I'm not going to use it
anymore
that's what I think
y'all are y'all are good for doing that
birthday my bro bubbles I'll roast you and
your Bunch are on Bubble Universe my room
for bugs bubble on that then
God dammit
yeah I'm rethinking it actually really
seriously
we talked about what DP driver I'm probably
going to use to give you a driver
are you seeing proton that's all right
that's how I play Witcher yes I do
yeah but again if I'm running a window if I
put Windows on here I got OverWatch back to
is like a bunch of shit I can do that I
can't do right now and I know OverWatch can
run with a bunch of extra work on Linux I
know I know I know I don't I just want to
click on the button and have it work
an update is that I'm a back yet I didn't
update it
and damn it let's compare so let's do mini
Cube
my mind is swirling in the whirling right
now because you just so many options out
there and
Branch or desktop is just like Tron
everything up in the air I feel like I need
to evaluate Rancho desktop immediately
because if Rancher desktop
God damn Prejudice account with a Linux
variation like right out of the out of the
gate to did you see that
alright alright alright alright alright
we're going to do some Rancher I have to run
to this up if I wish right now you know why
because I can't rest until I know I have to
know if a renter desktop is going to replace
Docker desktop fully and stare for the booze
can use it and then everything that I do up
to that point can use it as well
on a weekend no I'm glad you said it right
now cuz we need to do do do it with you
should see you should see all the people in
my work slacks chat went out to like 900
people and they should see how many people
have liked it and and are like oh my God
this is awesome so by you telling me and
everybody else we all benefit from this like
immediately and and I feel like this
derailment has been valuable I can tell you
right now that you're sharing that bit of
fresh news has provided dollar value to my
business because my business has just
reevaluated a ton of decisions that have
saved I don't know how many total person
hours
and and that is like real fucking cash right
there because you
because you share that with us so I don't
want you to feel bad about that you just
saved a ton of people a ton of time
yeah and
I wish I could give you the rewards I wish I
could have asked I asked which people I like
hey can I and that's what you call the
people who notice people like I want to be
able to give bits to my people seriously I
want to buy a ton of bits and I want to be
able to give bits to my audience
and I want to be able to give y'all B on
problem with that is if they do that if they
do that there's going to be all kinds of
money laundering going on so you can't
really do it
hey and they won't do it because of money
laundering because people would just buy a
ton of bits and give him off and then you
know they can already kind of money
laundering with them that it was serious
loss like a 40% loss
it's user hat is a channel right
I think I think you choose or is a channel I
have you have to go to their Channel and
give them B
he just says if you get partnered
I know I think that they should do it I
think
look I would buy I would like pay like 500
in B and when people give me B I would want
to redistribute the wealth to people who are
providing more than just giving people VIP
so like today I would be giving Brianna a
big fucking bitch you know when I would for
something like that and you know anytime
somebody provides a lie to me I want to get
them back I don't want to give him points of
stuff in a moats and all I want to be able
to actually give them I know you wouldn't
want it but but there's there's I want to be
able to actually pay people for her I don't
want to create the wrong you know tone here
I just
yeah but my point is that we get we're all
sharing around something up but I miss her
so much to that I I would I would want to be
able to to get back at him
kids YouTube videos about rounded us up yeah
go watch that in an invite us gaming if if
you're new to Linux in general please let us
know what you think please let us know what
you think because because I'm particularly
interested in what beginners think of it I
know you you think all new nobody cares
that's the opposite because your new your
opinion is more valuable than those have
been doing this for a long time to me
because because I want to say I want to ask
you point-blank what what did you get hung
up on how easy was it to use did you get you
know these are this is really really
valuable information to someone who's doing
mentoring
so please your just as valuable to our
community the beginners are every bit of
that more is valuable because they aren't
helping us identify ways to to help others
and give you skills so let's switch this so
I would do any cube in a cube
I'm a junior system in awesome he will your
dry place then we're going to do all kinds
of amazing things
so it's a great job and I love I love this
job
I'm just checking my my screen
probably set up and refocus are all right so
let me delete this close to her and I'm
going to delete his dinner I'm going to make
it cost without a driver I'm going to use
that the other KVM one so we're going to do
delete NSP test weight node off lab
give me delete that burst of lackluster I'm
going to change my build script to
change the driver I want to see the default
actually if I don't do that it'll use a
darker driver I don't want to do
so driver KVM to write
I think it is
UPS
what is it that we need to do so we have
where's the driver driver driver driver
is she and I plug into use oh my God
we can put Calico on that by default I did
not know you can set your calculator. Oh my
God that's all fucking awesome
if I do that then I'll be like like that'll
be like the one I'm using now the king run
time use dr. Kennedy
shit this is cool because I can recreate my
same system
I'm not a fan of openstack personally how
many is proxmox
see if used to Creole delete disable driver
mounts
oh I don't use a bigger and communities lab
though
I don't know I want to use that lab also I'm
actually a gym trying to test this out
because my thought is that many people
should be able bit faster for this kind of
thing even though the baker Community Club
is fucking amazing to they're all good so
that gives multiple ways to do this is I
think the takeaway here is it there multiple
ways to use kubernetes depending on the task
at hand you know and and that that is
something I really really really want to put
in a chart of some kind or some kind of
graphic when do you pick kind when do you
pick mini cube when you pick mini cube with
this driver when do you pick vagrant when do
you pick a cloud you know there's a lots of
them
oh shit Canadian hyper-converged
infrastructure with Harvester
modern Canadian
assassin people can damn it I love Rancher
it was like a chain or codes oh my God
oh my God
what is this hardware virtualization with
virtualization so they can buy in the
virtualization with the
shit shit too much to keep up with but thank
you for telling me about that. That is so
cool
this so cool
then why are you sexy yeah oh my God that's
crazy awesome
it's as smooth as a fast-moving train isn't
it people it's hard to keep up its hard to
keep up with moving so fast
dr. Damon no doctor download no pod-man
driver is virtualbox VMware Fusion
give him two
I mean what does a default to default to
Auto detect so KVM to
video game to yam
turn off lamp I want to see if that much
faster this is we should time this
California mini sir
oh my God it's so much faster like a ton
faster
it's busier hypervisors busy
yeah SLK is caving in because my advisors
busy going to do another shit yeah
I thought I know I do everything on what it
what is the things on
don't forget to reimage everything
Note offline I mean guess is not running
oh God
I got to tell you that liver is much
prettier
hey there we go I understand
wait what
running me to delete me fix it I did do that
I swear to God I did that
yeah I mean let's be real live vert is way
faster and smoother on Linux
it is that's not a fucking Oracle product
and I really don't give a shit about about
virtualbox because I'm not going to be doing
graphic Linux distros in a virtual machine
ever
the only reason I had that on there is
because people like to try things out before
they buy them but you could also just get an
old piece of hardware and try out all the
dishes on that and see how hard it is to the
install
so I'm I'm I'm today's Rancher thing
has really really really take my interest in
virtualbox
for a Linux VM because you're a kid and you
want to figure out if you want to use I3 or
no more our shit
like I do the veterans out there you don't
know why that would be a thing and you
people that are attracted to my channel like
the terminal and stuff but to the general
look YouTube is full of people fighting
tooth and nail over what the best Lennox
prawn is based on what does Roller using
right so there's two ways to do that if
you're if you're a distro junkie and you
really like the look and feel of a desktop
Linux then
yeah we all started to get use it that way I
don't think that's bad I didn't I I learned
from the terminal and yeah
I'm dead on my job how can I use Google is
well I mean you don't need a graphic event
for that but yeah
is a Xavier a jump that's right and so I
think y'all are you can just leave the point
I'm trying to make is that you need a
desktop right
and if you want that desk talk to me Linux
you need to try that but it's in a part of
infrastructure engineering I don't think it
is also the reason the reason I'm I'm I'm
having second thoughts about this because of
the Rancher just something is because the
infrastructure engineering boost is
primarily designed to give you skills that
involve using Linux as a server not
necessarily as a desktop if you wanted
that's nice but it's not a core critical
path requirements to become an
infrastructure engineer I think you can do
the job complete me from you no Windows or
Mac and I know I do I'm not allowed to have
a litter box for my job currently they will
not give me a Linux laptop
it won't give me an iPad Pro and then send
it to get rid of yourself to issue they will
only give you a Windows machine or a Mac so
you're that you don't have a choice to using
Linux on your desktop there for desktop is
fun it's beautiful it's great all of that
it's also irrelevant when it comes to jobs
that are related to the next unless your job
is providing a desktop environment like I
don't know about over something
Tory songs are playing YouTube channels
right it's crazy
this up any mental or restrict my aunt so
many countries restricted to Mac or Windows
repair using Linux desktop feels right and
it's so I'm not I really want to be clear
here I am not slamming on people who wanted
and Lennox on their desktop I'm just saying
it's irrelevant to Enterprise work in
infrastructure engineering and Cloud native
so having a Linux desktop is
dude I was on today just today right today
the guy who showed me that you noticed
they're all using throw using putty
they're doing their entire job people in
other people to make it for $50,000 a year
using putty it's it losing party or the
using SSH client they're not didn't even
they don't even have one and I'm the one
who's using your cell and I have Lenox and
I'm and I'm like oh my God how are you doing
that because they don't even use them until
2:30 to see pretty in these are young kid
some of them they're not compare to me
they're not it's not like they're a bunch of
old greybeards it just you know they got
stuck using S6 remote these are people
that's that's how work is getting done so
the reason I'm going on this tirade is cuz
I'm I'm continuing to justify the position
but you can do with Rancher desktop of
dropping the choice
drop it will say this dropping the can Ican
I test desktop Linux with it as a Criterion
or first selection of a technology that you
that you learn
Saudia
and finance guys would have to use when I
said it breaks the main reason they don't
want lennox's cuz they can't control it I
also by the way another thing I am not
allowed it's against security policy of our
company for me to install virtualbox on our
laptops this site has blocked you can't
download anything if you do download it
they'll report you for it I can't run
virtualbox
I'm not allowed to run it so I really want
to look at this other options and see if it
gets approved by security right now is
probably not being blocked by the security
so we might have a good chance that if I
don't know where to find out if I block him
and so I installed as well so I'm going to
be really interesting to see you some more
next to him cuz he's our killer clear yeah I
don't like that stuff because it's all
remote I can't build images and stuff unless
I have a connection and I called like 10
years ago if it's switch the results they
had they will eventually but they don't like
my team still on it like a background do
most things from the 7-Eleven yeah
if no I think it's right I think light is
better and to be as low as possible that
enrolls in Enterprises
I love the Linux Bible it's pretty old and
the best thing I would do is
the Linux command line from William shots
it's a little dated but it's the best book
that I know of for Lenox right now
hey I got that pretty looks pretty emotes
I know where's the Box
I might change my mind tomorrow so don't
hold me to it I haven't tested it all
depends on Rancho desktop all of it depends
on Rancher to stop and I haven't which means
I kind of wanted to Serena so I do want to
bring this up though first it said it is
giving me shit because it says
node any other name in wrong
profiles I was still there no wonder
I know I didn't give him to what the fuc
I think we're going to check it out yeah but
I'm going to check it out I want to just
give you something really quick and then
we'll check it out
I don't think it's going to install because
I already have a ton of Darker shade
installed
I don't think I I don't think I should
install it on this machine I think I should
install it on my Windows machine maybe I'll
get my
i r l camera or something
we don't need to check it out y'all need to
check it out let me know we already have one
really big report that came into I don't
remember who did it we had a Mac and one
user reports that that ran for desktop works
with the M1 Max and Linda and virtualbox
does not as a huge huge bit of info right
there
since Sunday I don't think that that's just
it's pretty much just sailed system be as
the defaults on everything that matters
whether or not I like it is irrelevant so I
don't really spend time talking about that
too much you know
he was a reporter a Victor Victor Victor I
forgot to bitu
any of the IP for you I just wanted you to
people who help us
and again I would be paying you B and stuff
like that if I could but I can't so that's
all I can do is because I don't know how
many is 25 or something
yeah I know but that's just a fun thing to
do so
well that's why I hear so many cubic delete
that's be node load off lab
now what I don't understand is when I run
the build script last time
it seems to not like it at first and then
after that it was kind of okay makes me
wonder if there's something in there that's
not working
give that a shot
what are we doing case you just joined us
what kind of all over the board this is I
call this co-working cold learning we're
just all over everybody sharing news and we
learn about the run for desktop today and
but we are I am at work I'm trying to do
things for work
are they able to actually take something and
somebody told us and report it to my work
and about renter to stop and it's crazy
value for that so it's called co-working
it's the same thing we would do if we were I
want a coffee shop or Panera Bread together
or French Bistro
did I say that
lvg you know me too well
you know it but I do my credits it wasn't my
fault
ice nobody's fault it's a good thing right
it's pretty normal I forget about it
up hey if there's like some hitch in
minikube where the it doesn't take the first
time and then the second time it does
I don't get it I like it's like I have some
left over from the previous one
privyet in the peace that are still too
political.
I wish we was just curious room kagaya
about about about them Jessica's all right
... Is it a scam
no.
Miss Rhonda
needles liquor stores actual new at least
that your garage door to National Community
Middle School
Cusco Peru whiskey community
he actually means of s it really is well
said
I'm honest honest honest honest sub shiver
if it's at the flower
is Chill Vibes exit have a working four days
closer we do now
so Jessica said she has two specific this is
Bulgaria Bulgaria
obsessed obsessed
suggest suggest I suggest this is a thing we
like Russian troops right so she just she
just is like is like society and saw a COS
like with so it means like with Society you
know you can like learn words with extra
Latin roots in Russian if you learn the
roots you can figure pretty much any word
out by learning The Roots down Jarvis's book
Russian Roots is hands-down the best way to
learn Russian because if you learn the
Russian routes you can sound out pretty much
any word you can figure it out even make up
words that are they do make sense of people
even if it doesn't exist
hey we got it we have an oh dear
08 MKS hsp90 test lab
damn it damn it
profile list oh hey it's running
is running learning things I agree so CD
docker yes as soon as he is running
hey we just have the one controlling running
right now what the fuck uh-oh right because
you don't have that's kind yeah I have a
kind
yeah I have kind of clusters running out of
many composers running
let's go look at liver really quick because
you mind did
I'm back to liver
so here's a problem if I start using live
right now welcome everybody if I start
losing lovebird for everything instead of
the box then I don't and I don't have the
graphic thing I'm going to have to use a
command line for everything
which is that a bad thing right verse yes
yes yes either we go yeah I'll be glvc read
my mind
Catherine of fasteners
let me listen be real if you're going to
encounter virtual machines in the wild there
going to be KVM machines
prove me wrong prove me wrong
he's a virtual machine on the desktop for
graphic environment is going to run off
consumer-grade kind of thing has nothing to
do with him should you drink if you're going
to use a virtual machine in the wild and
chances are it's going to be liver to KVM
and that's what I was on yours is set for
there for learning live vert versus age
virtual manager and KVM and chemo is far
more relevant to becoming an infrastructure
engineer then learning average box
Richard boxes is in that you know let's
fight over I3 versus know I'm kind of thing
you know it's it's it's it's it's something
to talk about it's completely irrelevant for
getting worked on understanding how KVM
works is far more relevant and I think
that's what attracted me to it to 2 weeks
ago so I am happy you need boxes your family
it is it is it is but yeah but in this case
were not looking for user-friendly in this
case were looking for Enterprise you know
and I feel like
alright so let's
hey Nicks Nicks Nicks Nicks Nicks Nicks
anyway so many Q
MK SSH m k s a c h s p test
all right list
okay profile smk I made my own newest thing
mksh to node
offline that's control my I come I can't go
to the control plane
oh my God aesthetic City MO
Roberta Superuser have a great day and see
if
oh I would not said we didn't switch the
profile oh my God I feel so silly you know I
took the music kind so much
yeah me to give us a lot more options
yay and it probably sent me to
look at me I know.
I think I think you could actually go to the
specific ones
how do you get ammo first console
I wish it holyshit like a full-blown console
oh my gerd
yeah Levert way liver is really the way I
mean List agree
it's just so much faster than it's much
faster
yeah yeah
you know what this means the right that the
whole day grinch it's going to have to
change over to deliver it again
yeah we did we got live at working with big
rent at the end at the end and then I
changed because I was like oh yeah but users
want to learn Universal boxes it's the way
in Vigor and has it and now I'm like on the
I know I'm like on the fence on the whole
thing again Baker is really the Tipping
Point you know it's kind of like
I think it's a 02 yeah that's what I wanted
to do
what's Escape it's this one I think that
again
everyone this is 01 or 02
yeah
oh if it doesn't support additional this how
am I going to do my volume test
that was the main thing
LBC you reminded me of the main reason that
was this single major driver for me to use
virtualbox to so I was doing the volume test
thing is because I can add up volume
you can't add a volume with the liver method
of vagrant that means either we throw
vagrant out
yeah it does weigh 230 vagrant out or yeah
we tried to reform and it fucking failed
miserably
enter form has a built-in virtual virtualbox
driver I don't know I apparently have to
know them both
cell I don't know
and I don't know I don't know I can't think
that I'm going to lose my mind I will lose
my mind all right Kay dead
he getting those are they are
can't get no national wide what's the IP
wait what
I said they're in. I know that sometimes you
never mind
we've learned a ton yeah
write things down a DoTerra phone with
Levert
as I've said multiple times I would rather
learn terraform than vagrant
you get more money learning terraform then
you will learning vagrant you probably no
vagrants is rubbing on Ruby
in the movie Stripes with ansible yeah
that's what I like that's exactly what I
want to do
but I but I thought you couldn't use
terraform unless you had a cloud which means
you had to do proxmox that was a whole
conclusion if you if you can prove me wrong
on that oh my God I would love it I would
love to be wrong on that we Surfer music
what we try to do in case you're just
joining us we tried to not use old and
busted vagrant right we tried
lover traditional dis yeah but it's not as
easy as not like it's not like a single
lined
you couldn't give me a n e h n e h. 9 years
ago and I'm the six year old zip code is a
container orchestration framework primarily
used by the Enterprise if you don't know
what containers are it's kind of hard to
help you with that I might want to research
what are containers Taylor from has a liver
provider have you tried it yes I did
we tried the liver provider didn't work
no add some sort of like major problem it's
a really really old provider first of all is
used to support date is like really really
old
is it a single line
is it the disc line did they did they
support under experimental
Limerick stores this is new this is a
plug-in that's why yeah is a plug-in
yeah this is fantastic thank you for this
yeah the vagrant liver support was it was
not good
I'm telling you it was not good we had
problems with it I'm going to try to get no
I am willing to try it again yeah I am
yep no ways of it
I have to go add this to my notes because
you you're cuz you're making me you're
making me
I if you going to send me links I'm not
doing it we're not going to do it right now
will you do it later
do do watches like what the fuck I mean
let's let's let's go soft white or no for
safety and do what do the exercise we're
good to go we we are using KVM this time
there's just so many ways and so many
different virtualization options I'm really
sorry it's so confusing for beginners that's
just the way it is but you got to know all
the things these people were talking about
if you want to become an infrastructure as
you got to be able to weigh these choices
you know against each other in an Enterprise
scope
camera down
I-10 eventually until the weekend yes right
so yeah lots and lots of twelve-year-olds
get started actually at steelstacks so if
you don't know what to do or how to get
started go to this
and when it says to install Docker desktop
replace that with Rancher desktop
not go go for that that's that's the new my
new Boost instructions
as of today
cuz the shit is changing every fucking day I
don't know what people do who have like
curriculum that they've got solidified and
papers and books and shit like that how the
fuck are you supposed to keep up but won't
charge people for your up-to-date anise and
people do whether you're a boot camp or
college I don't see how they do it
this is a major major breakthrough and you
know nobody's even knows about it they will
cancel it even know about it for another 6
months to cancel know about it for six
months and then when they know that I do
have to consider where they're going to
change all their documents if he's going to
rewrite the docks and everything this is why
the Boost that I've been doing have always
been very loose and knew every single year
because you just it's just it's absolutely
new stuff and most of his verbal and I just
write an outline because if I had to write
it all down and won't do anything else
so
it's it's part of the it's part of the game
though and if you remind is spinning and I
called fuck I don't ever want to get into
this Indiana probably get to know because it
is you got to keep up is hard right so
now let's go ahead and do some appointments
right get notes so these are ordering. He's
can paint to look at 3 knows what's a note
to know what is I noticed a machine that is
running kubernetes stuff on it back we can
actually show you that we can do mksh and
this will take you on to the control plane
and we can actually SSH into the different
things here we can get your charger for
nodes and now I'm actually connected to a
Docker node
is the way life it is his lunch though and
so darker what is our darker password I do
not know
password password docker
I don't know what it is
someone look up what is the default
mini q no machine password
and password faster is username default
login is Docker password
TC user what the hell
I don't want to do that so there
I don't I'm going to emulate what I would
have to do an environment without Brewers
age that's why
I know
so it would only be SSH access from the
control planes into the nose that's how my
environment is right now you can't get to
the notes reservation once you get on a
control plane and I want to follow that
process just doesn't matter of course even
though I know I can cheat and used to go
straight at it so no offense sir but it's
that's what I'm doing here
and then I SSH into Jose k k Jose k k get
notes
k f c t l get nude
what do you mean there's no qvc2
can you see I'm going to have to I know I
know don't what don't worry you're the
hearts I do my extra large
and I love you this is all part of it so X4
cute fig
Etsy I know it's easier for her to say I
know I can hear you saying that I can hear
you saying it
there's not are you sure guess not
I just abscess themes guess not
what the fuck are these things
shitt I don't what kind of Destroyer is this
how do you identify the distro
motd that's what we used to do that's not it
Alice be released or some shit
I strip down Lennox I think it is actually I
just don't know what kind of wood it is
yeah yeah I tried your name
and I did not want to ask just go to Lenox
at the OS releases yes yes yes yes that's
the one I was looking for
building routes
name buildroot version dirty
this is a very unique they made their own
Lennox
yeah go Boston major in Linux so you can't
install anything on it forget that another
reason to use like
alavert sort of situation right I mean
another reason to use the vagrant using
liver is waking to be at we can actually
install stuff on there
yes
yeah you learn something everyday huh it was
eat its US release
I think you'll be under that yeah I can do
that
the guy over here now just just I have never
seen this before doctor run oh God there is
a doctor run shit
yeah because it has darker you can do all
that stuff that's so cheating as Sonics
I really don't need any of that stuff so the
world is your oyster absolutely
yeah yeah there is that's what I thought was
so weird II sources
ice I Source the admin thing do you keep CDL
I know it's got to be a cubit running over
here right
yeah there it is okay what
Entertainer yeah you could do that but this
is
as many as when you can have Mount options
I don't think make it hasn't as Mount
options yeah that
it is definitely a cutie instead of it
absolutely that's what they said they said
it was a committee instead of
so but there's no Cube ATM over here it just
are you just going to scroll down to see
what you see. I don't I don't need you that
because you know why I can do it from over
here
I canI can to keep Caesar from here so I'm
good
what I was trying to do was get on to the
endpoint so that I could see how many
containers of stuff we're running over there
I wanted to see how how real it is you know
and say yeah
I want to say
and it should give you a name with the notes
you don't it was built with you ATM but it
doesn't require Community shift with notes
most of the stuff that I've had his head
through those three things on it though he
will incubate him in Tuesday deal even
though it's not required just for the sake
of ministration right but it does make your
note heavier
yeah I know mksh will just get you on there
which girl and it actually has girl
again it's supposed to be tiny right so
I'm pretty sure I can assist age directly
into a box
yeah there it is there it is so I can assist
age Dash in
and I can do off test lab
is there a 1 what is it
manifest completion it does not it does not
have an equation
get nodes can get nodes
oh no. Flaps are you knowed all 50 states
so it's two and three you got to be kidding
me
I got to be there to go yeah thank you so
there we go we can go look at our container
I think this is enough I think this is
enough for sure but you only think this is
not working kind kind is not set up all your
outing for you got to do it on your own by
the big disadvantages of a kind of romantic
uneq gives you closer okay so kind gives you
like the ultimate in bare-bones nests and
uses doctor for everything mini Q gives you
gave me a man gives you the opportunity to
use a virtual machine which could you send
me the login too and it in a real way you
can still connect with kind into the systems
but they are not they don't have storage
devices and shit like that and you can
connect and then the other way would be
something like vagrant or terraform
and I would save up right before the big
rent in between there and then terraforming
the next level but we're going to run to try
really seriously to get terraform to work
locally with live bird and I think that that
would
love you much better
containers let me call the Elms absolutely
not people know this but some people might
not and you can do a lot of virtual machine
testing and development everything we just
containers and not use actually comes but
then you kind of need to step over he's
being what's wrong
or people. I think you're right I think
you're right especially people watching
right now yeah I didn't know your
differences important right has Paige it's
like it talks about the history of the
components communities and it's a really
great diagram of the top and it gives you
the history of you know traditional server
client architecture and then virtualization
and then containerization and how they've
all tried trade out some of the years I also
have a sale casting on the end
I wish I could find it KVM
I'm surprised now this is just how they do
things differently at Santa Rosa different
image
if sometime so we're good let's let's
actually get some shit running on no 2 by
doing an appointment this is what you came
here for if you if you dialed in for
discussing this is why you're here
if I do a.m. and
well drink right now with all the breaking
of the cleaner thing so we need to do some
stuff I put in bill this cuz I want some
place to store my commands not for any other
reason really just kind of messy again I
don't want to have to go back to my history
and find out I can but I just like to do
here in about two I'll put it in the
function of whatever so let's
so let's do this let's make a thing so so
cute t t l
let's just make an appointment the create
appointment fun it's one of the few things
you can make the command line there there
was a four or five things you can do for the
command line to create appointment without
any I will file other things you cannot do
that with
find us one of a nice whatever we want we
just going to put a bunch of shit in there
that's like really busy right we should put
this floor in there should be put it in
there
I mean we deployed it I could totally do
that
it's good she should create deployment image
or X Rob
it's just feel right what did I call I can
remember I think it's filled those yeah
Advil disc
so if we made this we made a container from
a French go container
yeah it doesn't feel it that much but let's
try that
so we got to go to name hahaha
I need to we're going to put a lot of shit
in there that's the whole point
I'm going to put a ton of shit in there
to make a milk container of filling disk
I don't know how much this kid has we can't
even check it you can't look at how much
just cuz on his system actually no we can
write we have to go to the underlying system
which sucks I hate this so SSH
got how can we even report on the disk
Yugioh zacian we can't we have to make
another thing for that Damon said the
reports on the disc has a Shinto the log I
know you can like do a thing right
I sent said I sent the application of
communities application coming at 10
come on are you all right
you can go lay down. Need you all right so
SSH mksh
I wonder if it does it just it's a
deployment so wait this is one of the only
have one that's already got it already over
from scratch on this dizzy boxer Alpine yeah
so I don't even know where is running okay
again pause that show wide
moo haha it's only winning one replica fuck
that we need to fix that
that's far too few we definitely need to
change this
damn it how can you represent like more than
one I'm going to do an actual appointment or
night I don't want to
QFC Seattle
create appointment I have to do they read
what you said
so this time tab
what is it is it rev I don't think I can do
a whole replica set stuff like that right
yeah now we can actually keep running it
like five of them
like this as soon as he has said why do we
doing this because we want separate jobs
right
yes
yes I don't know a skeleton planet that is
spelled the same container
picking up no neck sweater
for I in 1 to 20 I do
do this move haha I
done yes
here we go oh
as if it was in front of the bar then no no
no I don't think I put mine in my own local
mom-mom Ashton yeah most of the stuff you
put in your own thing
does a doctor have yeah which is bad I need
to tell me what tell me if I need to move on
soccer hub I do
and those are going to get slammed we want
them to get slammed that's the point
all right so nationalwide
and he at least it distributed it and it
includes the control plane I think I'm going
to get him
oh my God he told Tony fall we've been down
the ranch Odessa thing a whole day 369
Anton wait how do we have that many nodes
out of this is the internal IP cuz pods have
their own IP
do there we go
is anybody ever remember actually watching
The Three Stooges on television
cuz I do
the Virginia Lottery what is it still works
my fan is on right now
my fan is definitely on right now
all right Eagles Boomer I know I know
I am barely I'm like 4 years from shy from
Boomer. So I know Boomer should like eunuchs
thank and gaming
when I supposed to meant I haven't switch
yet I have not switched if I probably not
probably in the switch to Mac
did I see what I did there
holy shit this is like blowing my my stuff
up I get my mind computer is not happy right
now
you see what I mean I already got happier
still is pretty fucking every one of those
every way I can top Santilli every one of
these things is spitting out as fast as it
can
I can't believe is this doing that well holy
cow
well I don't even what that means yeah I
still can have them or
I know yeah
I can't believe it's handling it I thought
it would kill me I might still streaming
it says I'm still streaming 48 till is 300
km per second 5000 K per second
I know it's sink is I'm not going to run
sink fuck no
and that's what you meant by Sync okay why
would I sink during the middle of a run like
this look at all these look at these live
birds around and see this
Albie's key moose am I used to swap I
haven't slept all night
I hope sheds my swap is getting tags
should I try to turn swap off I have so I
can swap off and watch it fucking die
it was freezing a computer it would totally
freeze my computer
I don't think it would
I know what I'm blowing up my machine and
purpose but this is kind of fun how do we do
our tanks and Toleration should
oh oh oh oh I'm getting a phone call from
some random person
all right that was an important call but I
have to go
read an NFL team
see you guys
imma be back I'm going to be back I just I
need to eat and something
no it was not was not it was my recruiter
is my recruiter are you guys I'm going to
say it again I'm going to say it again okay
my recruiter
is going crazy cuz they cannot fill these
positions
and they're asking me questions about what
what should we look for who we who do we
need when we doing things I'm going to say
it again if you have
if you have a kubernetes cluster that you
are running at home
and you set up yourself
askew
if you fuc so
I was going to say it if if you have a non
Prime committee's closer that you administer
yourself
and you can talk about intelligently and you
know all the pieces and even better if you
have some knowledge of how to read go and
some knowledge about basic networking
infrastructure engineering and you want a
job that's going to be like above what I do
I know they're all hired we cannot find
anybody been a year-and-a-half and can't
find him I tell you what those people
those people are writing their own fucking
ticket right now manbe there there go
they're they're actually talking about going
back to the client and and saying you need
to give us another 100K because they can't
get people for the price that they're asking
for
and you know I don't want to talk about much
I make but the amount of money that I
already make is crazy I mean it's crazy to
me how much should I know it's not crazy to
the people work in Silicon Valley it's like
free racing pretty reasonable but I'm just
trying to say there is work out there for
those who want it
you're never he stills
so this is really great that's why I talked
to a recruiter so long ride because when I
talked to a recruiter and they're trying to
say hey how can we they just they put a
couple people in front of my employer or
contractor write it put a couple people and
they got turn down you know when I get
turned down because they were too much into
the cloud
not getting you I am so glad that I'm
focusing on on friend
are there is there something that I realized
it from that conversation I really want to
write about this probably should write as I
do about this
I first Linux admin job while you're on your
way you're on your way and don't under
understand you know keep learning repeating
what Leon says here you got to getting the
job is just the first step then you got it
you know keep learning and develop yourself
when you got in of the pressure's off right
so you got to keep doing it it's also kind
of on at the same time because you know you
got a massive imposter syndrome when you
first get hired everybody does
infrastructure engineering and specifically
cloud-native anything with cloud-native in
the name
Cloud native is the key word to search for
not that mops search for cloud native and
search for kubernetes and search for on-prem
okay and that they interviewed and I should
probably put this in a video the person that
they interviewed that they decided not to go
with with somebody who had a lot of cloud
experience and was just barely getting into
on from
and I believe I have enough of ejected
evidence at this point to say
learning how to run your own
no you don't need to search I don't think
you do know they I did they would hire
people without the store tents down the
position of trying to fill the guy had no
service at all ever never in them
and I've I've talked to other hiring
managers in this chat who have said I'll
take somebody with a non Prime cluster that
they've built and maintained and can talk
about it intelligently way more than I'll
take some of the cert desserts are not going
to hurt in this case right they're not going
to hurt they're not going to admit this is
specifically I'm going to give you a bit of
information that it's not classified but
it's I think it's very valuable the specific
feedback for this experience Cloud engineer
who was turned down by this job was that
they had too much glad experience not enough
on from experience
add they did not have him answer Jimmy they
did not have they were looking specifically
for people who had Advanced our back roll
for Missions experience and we're dealing
with multi-tenant multi cluster
interactivity and they can make you know not
just one not two but three they can have and
make a deal with multiple clusters for
different needs and set up different
permissions and be able to cousin to get to
communicate with one another that was this
specific reason this engineer was turned
down that and probably other other issues I
don't know but that was the main issue and I
that's a very choice piece of information
and I got that because I've maintained a
really positive relationship with my
recruiter my recruiter regarding calls me
and I said it before if you want to get a
job and keep a job it's about making
personal connections and I know about this
recruiter through a person that I met on
this live stream so
getting a job and keeping a job is about
it's about the human connection about
everything else but you know that is I would
have paid money to have that feedback I
seriously I would have paid good money to
have heard that recruiter give me the
feedback about why the candidate didn't make
it
because now I can share that with you
on-prem multi-cloud so actually because
based on that in put this is what I want to
do they still hadn't put I want to do this
already but I am going to make
but I am going to make multiple clouds at
home
and have them talk to each other separate
and I'm going to use terraform to do it
their all the virtualization on a proxmox
think that's I'm definitely going to make
that before the end of the year because then
what you do is you can like you can
reprovision multiple Cloud you can have your
say I want to put a customer here comes over
here and then you can test them all out you
don't homelab and yes you're going to pay
for latency and and virtualization not 30%
performance but who cares you're going to be
able to test it all in multiple different
configurations you should have it if you
really want to work in this job if you
really want to work and it's on on this
cloud-native job I don't think I've ever
felt more strongly you need a home lab with
multiple multiple cores were talking like
you know total of like I'm probably 20 to 40
Kors total you know and that's combined of
course across machines
and be able to do all the stuff and then we
connected with Submariner you do this is
multiple different on Prime Claws and then
connecting with Submariner yeah somebody was
telling me about something or the other day
was it you
yeah
yeah see it in that that that that kind of
experience is what people you know people we
should listen to it to Porsche and we're
just got a different architectural slant
then some of the other people in the channel
which is great we have got really seen your
people here who have deployed very complex
cloud-native on friend things and have
different opinions about how to do that we
have some you know openshift people we have
some some people who have done nothing but
Rancher I think forces Rancher and we have
people that you know they just all sorts of
different opinions on that on that level so
we have some great exposure here to teach it
to doing this and of course my goal is to
create the best possible home simulation lab
to explore any of those possibilities so
that you can play around with hey I want to
I want to this weekend I'll say Christmas
break I'm going to shift everything over the
open shift
I'm just going to play the open shift for
the whole Christmas to you know and then I'm
going to see if everything back over here
and I'm going to get a sense of all of them
and then it every time you do that you can
put stuff on your CV and erasing me that
says you've worked with it even if it's your
own experimental lab it totally counts as a
project and you can list and then when you
go to do the job interview you can say you
say they said they will tell us what you've
done is it while I made my own I maintain my
own you know 15 old live at home like how do
you do that was something that we can figure
it to do the X and Y and Z I'm not doing
that right now that's my goal right that's
my goal to be able to do that but I think be
able to celebrate and if some of that stuff
is GPU if you're doing GPU machine learning
jobs on top of that you fucking golden
because a lot of these on private places
there doing why are they doing on Prem
they're going to prom because you choose
expensive they want to rent it
didn't want to rent cheap you so they go on
friend with her closer to do machine
learning and now if you know how to do
machine learning which means you know how to
do you know when it is installed in in video
provisioning and stuff like that you need to
build it up
getting a hacker rank with me could
questions a red flag absolutely to me it is
as long as you level a skin test me on there
yeah I know I don't want nothing to do with
it
at the dead man we talked about that quite a
bit and I it's one of my biggest pet peeves
if a company doesn't they just look the
other way it's keep walking has
overwhelmingly convince me of that fact if
you if you want to go for a senior software
engineering job like where you're actually
doing you know computer science level
algorithms and coding and stuff like that
that's a totally different job than the job
that I'm preparing people for it might play
into that everything I'm doing is rep rep
for that if you as well if you want some of
it might be you know rabbit holes compared
to what you really need to focus on their
ask you to meet code is a different job than
the stuff that I'm helping people get lines
primary operations and and then they asked
me what scripting skills do you think they
should have I said issues with Bosch Python
and not a real pearl and Ruby and they
should be able to Rigo
imma stand up and walk away and go eat some
food and I'll be back again I'm not going to
drop the screen though it's just it's just
inconvenient for you to get so we're going
to my fan is still on so how is my computer
doing as my disc filled yet
here's the really cool thing my disk is not
going to feel because why
not going to feel because why cuz it's only
going to fill my individual volumes the
swamp is full of God
should I get rid of swap should I get rid of
swamp you dare me to
should I swap off it yeah
when is it worth swapping assistant is
approximately right
I can't remember swappiness is let him
Killer do its job that's that's what I want
to do yeah
I do want to do it's it's it's keeping up a
bunch of stuff that I've been a member yeah
it definitely is Aaron, this is not a real
thing
wait we we do those notes have small for
them they should not have some off on them
they shouldn't
if they do
Anaheim swap good night then I was off
2 GB so they're managing pretty well I think
it's funny though that
what swapping is mini Q the one swapping
who's swapping
yeah it is an HR hiring thing yeah
people get around the HR situation by
meeting human beings there in the job
already like me like recruiters like people
at conferences
is it Prague sloppiness I can't remember
where it was thank you well if I can't have
any cuz there's no swap
yeah I left my swap on a piss cuz I'm
streaming I don't know if I turn it off on
here
I remember changing this once upon a time
though so yeah
yeah I sent it to 10 while back that's in my
that's that's in my my bass or c
some place I can't remember where add to my
health at sunrise
I need to get from you I'm going to class I
might collapse anyway what time is it 6
already
shit
I don't know how
five parts of a lame jokes for the win
Seth I mean weed
I'll probably take 20 minutes maybe I should
just drop it listed at
let's go raid somebody and then I'll drive
I'll come back later because I don't want
people just sitting around
who is on are there any people on
oh hey there's a co-worker
hello my Yuko let's go Raiders
oh this is the first person I got murder
rate hello miyoko she's cool
yeah we're going to go we're going to
gogoing to rain hello Amaya cuz she's funny
she's a she's a co-worker
and I'll be killing this room and then
coming back later so I'll see you guys in a
bit
bye for now